programming throwdown episode 98 agile thinking with zen hub take it away jason hey everyone so we're here with aaron upright who's a co-founder at ZenHub. And, you know, I know agile is a really common term. I remember even hearing it in university before even taking any software architecture or software engineering courses. I just become very ubiquitous. But a lot of people don't know, you know, really what that means, what it entails. And so we have Aaron here who's founded a company that part of its core mission revolves around Agile to kind of dive deep with us and kind of explain what Agile is all about. Yeah, thank you guys. Thank you guys so much for having me. I'm really excited to be on the show
Programming Throwdown 第 98 期：与 ZenHub 一起探讨敏捷思维。Jason，请开始你的表演。大家好，今天我们请到了 ZenHub 的联合创始人 Aaron Upright。我知道“敏捷”（Agile）是一个非常常见的术语。我记得在大学里，甚至在还没上任何软件架构或软件工程课程之前，我就听说过这个词。它已经变得非常普遍了。但很多人并不真正了解它的含义，以及它具体包含什么。所以我们请来了 Aaron，他创办了一家核心使命围绕“敏捷”的公司，来为我们深入剖析并解释敏捷到底是什么。是的，谢谢你们，非常感谢你们邀请我。我很高兴能参加今天的节目。
today. Cool, cool. So why don't you tell us a bit about your background? Like what kind of led you to the path that got you here? Yeah, so I work on the go to market side of our business, which kind of captures everything from marketing, sales, success, basically following customers from kind of when they come to Zenhub and when they're kind of first interested to using the tool to how we kind of really make them successful. And my background actually isn't really typical for a founder of a developer tool company. I did a year of engineering when I was in university, but actually I dropped out of that program and completely switched what my focus was from an academic perspective. For whatever reason, I just found that academically engineering, being in an engineering program
酷，酷。那么，能给我们介绍一下你的背景吗？是什么让你走到了今天这一步？好的，我负责我们业务的“上市”（go-to-market）方面，这涵盖了从市场营销、销售到客户成功的所有环节，基本上就是从客户最初接触 ZenHub 并对使用该工具产生兴趣，到我们如何真正帮助他们取得成功。其实我的背景对于一家开发工具公司的创始人来说并不典型。我在大学时学了一年工程学，但我退出了那个专业，并从学术角度完全改变了我的重心。不管出于什么原因，我发现从学术上讲，身处工程专业
was a little bit isolating for know, isolating for me. And I really like the competitive aspect of having to compete against my classmates. But I love the concept of building things and making things. And I was always really fascinated with technology. And so academically, that led me down the path of actually going to business school where I finished my degree. And that's how I got involved in a lot of the go-to-market sides of Zen Hub. But when I graduated, I was looking for what is a way that I can apply this in a way that kind of really naturally fits with where my passions are and really naturally fits with technology. And so the answer for me at that point in time was saying, hey, can I join a really small startup
对我来说有点孤立。我确实喜欢与同学竞争带来的那种竞争感。但我热爱构建和创造事物的概念，而且我一直对技术非常着迷。因此，在学术上，这引导我走上了攻读商学院的道路，并最终完成了学位。这就是我参与 ZenHub 市场推广工作的原因。但当我毕业时，我一直在寻找一种方式，能将这些知识与我的热情以及技术自然地结合起来。当时对我来说，答案就是：嘿，我能不能加入一家非常小的初创公司，
or could I join something in the technical space to try to apply what I had learned in university with kind of what my passions were. I actually ended up in Vancouver, Canada, at a company called Axiom Zen. The idea, the hubris for Axiom Zen was a startup, you could say, that builds other startups, or almost a venture studio model. At the time, there were a couple of people that were working on an internal project called Zen Hub, really to address and fix a lot of the gaps that we saw in our own software development process at Axiom Zen. And kind of when I first found out about that, it was a very internal project, very kind of small scale thing,
或者加入某个技术领域，尝试将我在大学学到的东西与我的热情结合起来。我最终来到了加拿大温哥华，加入了一家名为 Axiom Zen 的公司。Axiom Zen 的理念或初衷是一家“构建其他初创公司的初创公司”，或者说是一种风险工作室模式。当时，有几个人正在做一个名为 ZenHub 的内部项目，主要是为了解决我们在 Axiom Zen 内部软件开发流程中发现的许多缺口。当我第一次了解到这个项目时，它还是一个非常内部、规模很小的东西，
but I immediately knew that I wanted to get involved in that. And so that's a little bit kind of of my background and how I came to be is one of kind of the core founding team members of what now today is the product we know as Zenhub. It's really interesting. I always thought, and I've never been to business school. You've been in both, so you'd be the authority here, but I always imagined business school as being really competitive. Yeah. I think it's interesting. It's competitive in different ways. What I was really craving, I think, in my education was the opportunity to collaborate and work on things with people. And it's kind of funny that I say that because so much of software development and so much of what we're going to talk about with Agile is all about how you collaborate and communicate better and come together to deliver products and to ship software.
但我立刻就知道我想参与其中。这就是我的背景，以及我如何成为今天我们所知的 ZenHub 产品核心创始团队成员之一的过程。这真的很有趣。我一直以为——我没上过商学院，你两者都经历过，所以你是这方面的权威——但我一直想象商学院是非常竞争激烈的。是的。我觉得这很有趣。它在不同的方面具有竞争性。我想我在教育中真正渴望的是与他人合作并共同完成事情的机会。说这话很有趣，因为软件开发和我们将要讨论的敏捷，其核心都在于你如何更好地协作、沟通，并团结一致来交付产品和发布软件。
But, you know, in the first year of engineering that I took it, I found it was a lot of assignment work, a lot of individual work on things. What I mean by competitive is that you're competing for the ability to specialize in a program at the end of the year, at least for the school that I went to. You'd be talking with your classmates and trying to work together on things and collaborate, and a lot of people that were in that program weren't really open to doing that. I'm painting a really broad brush here on engineering programs as a whole, because I know that not everyone is like that. And at the end of your program,
但是，你知道，在我学习工程学的第一年，我发现有很多作业，很多个人独立完成的工作。我所说的“竞争”是指，至少在我上的那所学校，你是在竞争年底进入某个专业学习的资格。你会和同学交流，试图一起合作，但那个专业里的很多人并不真正愿意这样做。我在这里对工程专业做了一个非常笼统的概括，因为我知道并非每个人都这样。在课程结束时，
you can get some really interesting things with capstone projects and things like that. But I was just craving for kind of more of that project work, I guess, throughout my undergraduate degree. And, you know, that's kind of where I found that. That totally makes sense. I think, I think that that is a really big issue. I took one course that really changed my life, kind of changed my PhD dissertation, like changed everything. And I think one of the reasons that that course was so impactful was the whole thing was just a set of projects. Yeah. And I feel like that is a really strong way to go. But it's, it's, it's an intense, it's intense on the, on the, on the professor. Yeah, for sure. I think that's one of the reasons why they don't do it.
你可以通过毕业设计（capstone projects）之类的项目做一些非常有趣的事情。但我只是在整个本科期间渴望更多这样的项目工作，我想，这就是我找到它的地方。这完全说得通。我认为这是一个非常大的问题。我上过一门改变了我人生的课程，它改变了我的博士论文，改变了一切。我认为那门课之所以如此有影响力，原因之一就是整个课程就是一系列的项目。是的。我觉得这是一种非常好的方式。但这对教授来说，压力很大。是的，当然。我认为这就是他们不这样做原因之一。
But I totally agree with you. I think that it's, it's a shame that some people do all of this. It's like they know how to invert a binary tree and they know how to do a lot of these things really well, you know, as an individual, but then maybe they haven't taken courses on working as a team. Yeah, for sure. And I think that teamwork component of it and learning how to work with other people
但我完全同意你的观点。我认为很遗憾，有些人做了所有这些。就像他们知道如何反转二叉树，并且作为个人，他们非常擅长做很多这些事情，但他们可能没有上过关于团队协作的课程。是的，当然。我认为团队合作的组成部分，以及学习如何与他人共事，
is one of the most valuable experiences you can build because you're going to have to immediately do that when you kind of step out of school or step out of university or college program and then enter the workforce so and actually i remember one of my favorite courses i think probably the favorite course i had of our undergrad degree actually or my undergrad degree was um where we we actually had a course that overlapped with computing science and so half the course or half the classroom was business students half the classroom was computer students, half the classroom was computer science students.
是你所能建立的最有价值的经验之一，因为当你走出学校、大学或学院课程并进入职场时，你必须立即这样做。实际上，我记得我最喜欢的课程之一——我想可能是我本科期间最喜欢的课程——是我们有一门与计算机科学交叉的课程，所以半个教室是商科学生，半个教室是计算机科学学生。
It was actually an elective for them and kind of a core course for us. But it was really cool because the whole kind of point of this course, and it was 100% project work, no exams, no finals, no midterms, was to come together and kind of build this website that was powered by a SQL database and all these different kinds of things. Obviously, we were able to work with students from CS, so they had more of a technical background. But the idea was that as business students, we were supposed to gather the customer requirements and do a lot of that ideating. That was actually the first time, too, that, funny enough, I was actually exposed to GitHub.
这对他们来说是一门选修课，对我们来说是一门核心课程。但这真的很酷，因为这门课的全部意义——而且是 100% 的项目工作，没有考试，没有期末考，没有期中考——就是聚在一起，构建一个由 SQL 数据库驱动的网站，以及所有这些不同类型的东西。显然，我们能够与计算机科学专业的学生合作，所以他们有更多的技术背景。但想法是，作为商科学生，我们应该收集客户需求并进行大量的构思。有趣的是，那也是我第一次接触 GitHub。
There's a funny story about that, too, because I think if you look on, you know, our team at Zen Hub, one of the things that we do sometimes is, you know, when new people come on board, you know, we look at like, well, how long have you been signed up for GitHub? How long have you been using it? And I actually have one of the oldest profiles on the team, despite not being a technical founder or between being a software engineer, because I signed up for this thing when I was in school to be able to work and collaborate with, with the rest of my classmates that were working on that project. So. That's awesome. So, so the yeah, I have a buddy who just happened to be as in the same university as, as Mark Zuckerberg. And I think he, his degree was in philosophy or something, but he has, he has like the eighth account on Facebook or something crazy like that. Maybe it's the 30th
关于这一点还有一个有趣的故事，因为如果你看看我们在 ZenHub 的团队，我们有时会做的一件事是，当新人加入时，我们会看：你注册 GitHub 多久了？你使用它多久了？尽管我不是技术创始人，也不是软件工程师，但我实际上拥有团队中最古老的个人资料之一，因为我在学校时就注册了这个东西，以便能够与参与该项目的其他同学一起工作和协作。所以。太棒了。所以，是的，我有一个朋友正好和马克·扎克伯格在同一所大学。我想他的学位是哲学之类的，但他拥有 Facebook 的第八个账户还是什么疯狂的东西。也许是第 30 个
account. And so his, his Facebook ID is like 20. Whereas for the rest of us, it's, you know, in the billions. That's funny. Yeah. It just sounds very serendipitous. Yeah, for sure. Cool. So, yeah, kind of walk people through sort of like what Agile is, especially, you know,
账户。所以他的 Facebook ID 是 20。而我们其他人，你知道，是在几十亿。这很有趣。听起来真是机缘巧合。是的，当然。酷。那么，引导大家了解一下什么是敏捷，特别是，
we have a lot of folks who are even in high school, maybe folks even younger than that. And they might have never worked on a team before, a team of software engineers. So how could you explain sort of Agile? Like, what is the value of that? And sort of how does it work? Yeah, I think it's a really interesting question. And I would kind of answer, I guess, in two parts of what is Agile then what does it mean to be agile? And I think a lot of the content, a lot of the writing out there, a lot of what you can go and find on agile tends to focus across all these different Agile terms, you're almost immediately kind of jumping into the deep end through that. I like to think about it, though, through the lens of what Agile means for our customers and for our end users. Because I think at the end of the day, we're all building and shipping software. And Agile offers frameworks in which to do that, in which to organize these.
我们有很多听众甚至还在上高中，甚至可能还有更年轻的人。他们可能从来没有在团队中工作过，没有在软件工程师团队中工作过。那么你如何解释敏捷呢？它的价值是什么？它是如何运作的？是的，我觉得这是一个非常有趣的问题。我想我会分两部分来回答：什么是敏捷，以及“敏捷”意味着什么。我认为很多内容、很多文章，以及你在网上能找到的关于敏捷的很多东西，往往会集中在所有这些不同的敏捷术语上，通过这些术语，你几乎会立即陷入深渊。不过，我喜欢通过敏捷对我们的客户和最终用户意味着什么的角度来思考它。因为我认为归根结底，我们都在构建和发布软件。而敏捷提供了实现这一目标的框架，以及组织这些工作的框架。
But really the value of Agile, I think, is what it means for the customer. And ideally, for all of us, that's getting software to market faster, getting software to market that's higher quality, that aligns with the value proposition behind our project. And really, I think what Agile comes down to, as opposed to maybe more traditional ways of working that I kind of grew up with in school and kind of learned about is really delivering value to our end users and our customers in smaller increments. I also think the idea of value is a really important one to think about in agile because if you're not delivering value, it doesn't really matter how you're working. You can come together and organize yourself in any way you want. But at the end of the day, if what you're
但敏捷的真正价值，我认为，在于它对客户意味着什么。理想情况下，对我们所有人来说，那就是更快地将软件推向市场，交付更高质量、与我们项目背后的价值主张相一致的软件。而且，我认为敏捷与我从小在学校学到的那种更传统的做事方式相比，其核心在于以更小的增量向我们的最终用户和客户交付价值。我也认为“价值”的概念在敏捷中非常重要，因为如果你没有交付价值，你如何工作并不重要。你可以聚在一起，以任何你想要的方式组织自己。但归根结底，如果你的
building isn't valuable to your customer or value to potential customers, you don't really have a project or a business. And I keep using the word customers, but I mean, that can be anything from people who use your open source project, that use your software in an unpaid or either a commercial standpoint. And yeah, I think about agile is the whole point of it is to deliver more value sooner to is to deliver more value sooner to our customers, more value sooner to our constituents. And I think at the end of the day, I would argue if you can do that and find ways to do that, irrespective of how you organize, you know, then you're working in an agile
构建的东西对你的客户或潜在客户没有价值，你就没有真正的项目或业务。我一直在使用“客户”这个词，但我的意思是，这可以是任何使用你的开源项目的人，无论是无偿使用还是商业使用。是的，我认为敏捷的全部意义在于更快地为我们的客户交付更多价值，更快地为我们的利益相关者交付更多价值。我认为归根结底，如果能做到这一点并找到实现的方法，无论你如何组织，那么你就是在以一种敏捷和
and iterative way. Yeah, that makes sense. So is this related to, you know, we just had a show on continuous integration and they talked about continuous deployment. So you do a push, it passed some tests and then right away, your customer gets it maybe within an hour. So that would be an example. You're moving to continuous deployment would be, that would be an agile endeavor. Exactly. There's under the, under the kind of broad strokes of agile, there's a lot of different ways that it gets physically implemented at companies. And like you said, CI, CD is one of those.
迭代的方式工作。是的，这说得通。那么这是否与——我们刚做了一期关于持续集成（CI）的节目，他们谈到了持续部署（CD）。所以你进行一次推送，它通过了一些测试，然后你的客户可能在一小时内就得到了它。所以这是一个例子。你正在转向持续部署，那将是一个敏捷的努力。完全正确。在敏捷的广泛框架下，公司有许多不同的物理实现方式。正如你所说，CI/CD 就是其中之一。
And I think for a lot of people listening to this, you know, it's important to kind of recognize where we kind of came from and where we are now in terms of our software development process. And not so long ago, and believe me, there's still companies out there. We get a look at this kind of still pretty frequently that are used to very kind of waterfall centric ways of shipping. And what I mean by that is these kind of really steep drop offs of like, all right, for the first three months of this project, you know, we're going to focus on the design phase. And once we're done with the design phase, it's permanently done, we're never going to come back and update those designs, those are locked in, we're moving on to the next phase, which is development, that's going to last another three months. And you know And we're going to be working on the
对于许多听众来说，重要的是要认识到我们在软件开发流程方面是从哪里来的，以及我们现在在哪里。就在不久前——相信我，现在仍然有这样的公司，我们仍然经常看到这种情况——他们习惯于非常以“瀑布式”为中心的发布方式。我的意思是，这些非常陡峭的阶段性跌落，比如：“好吧，这个项目的前三个月，我们将专注于设计阶段。一旦设计阶段完成，它就永久结束了，我们永远不会回来更新那些设计，它们被锁定了，我们进入下一个阶段，即开发，那将持续另外三个月。”你知道，我们将致力于
designs that we built from the last phase and working to actually codify those and to actually create those. And then once we're done with that development phase, it's permanently done. We move on to testing and so on and so forth in this very kind of waterfall-centric way where you have these kind of multiple step points. And that used to be the way that a lot of teams would come together, especially in large companies, and really develop software with these very phased approaches. And really what we've moved to more recently is these really short cycles and almost circular iterations where we design, develop, QA. That could generate feedback, though, that ends up changing the design somehow. And so we don't have to wait until the next version of the software, the next big iteration that we push out to actually make those changes. We can do that in a much more iterative way on the fly. And when you talk
我们在上一阶段构建的设计，并努力将其编码并实际创建出来。一旦开发阶段完成，它就永久结束了。我们进入测试，依此类推，以这种非常以瀑布为中心的方式，你有这些多个步骤点。这曾经是许多团队，特别是在大公司中，聚在一起并以这些非常分阶段的方法开发软件的方式。而我们最近更多地转向了这些非常短的周期和几乎圆形的迭代，我们设计、开发、QA。但这可能会产生反馈，从而以某种方式改变设计。所以我们不必等到软件的下一个版本、我们推出的下一个大迭代来实际进行这些更改。我们可以以一种更迭代的方式即时进行。当你谈论
about CICD, that's definitely a huge part of it because as you think about shorter cycles of design, development, testing, deployment, we need to be able to get software out way faster and make sure that it still goes through the same kind of passesmonth project that we deliver once and then it's in the hands of our customers and they use it for however long they use it for, CICD really came about so we can enable teams to ship a lot faster while still upholding a lot of the quality components that you need when you're producing software. Yeah, that makes sense. So what about for folks who are sort of pegged to a longer release cycle, how can they be agile? That's a really good question. I think it comes back to thinking about maybe some of the frameworks that you can start to implement around that. And I talked a lot about value and the core kind of principle of agile being, hey, let's figure out ways to deliver value to customers sooner. I think it's a little bit silly, though, not to acknowledge that there's a lot of really academic ways about thinking about Agile, too, and so much content that's been written about it, and so many, you know, so many essentially ways of working that have been documented,
CI/CD 时，这绝对是其中很大的一部分，因为当你考虑设计、开发、测试、部署的更短周期时，我们需要能够更快地发布软件，并确保它仍然通过同样的质量检查。对于那种交付一次然后就交给客户使用很长时间的项目，CI/CD 的出现确实是为了让我们能够使团队在保持生产软件所需的高质量组件的同时，发布得快得多。是的，这说得通。那么对于那些被锁定在更长发布周期的人来说，他们如何才能做到敏捷呢？这是一个非常好的问题。我认为这又回到了考虑你可以开始围绕它实施的一些框架。我谈了很多关于价值的问题，以及敏捷的核心原则是：嘿，让我们想办法更快地为客户交付价值。不过，我认为不承认敏捷也有很多非常学术的思考方式，以及已经写出的关于它的海量内容，还有许多本质上已经被记录下来的工作方式、
certifications, accreditations that you can get. So I guess to answer the question, for teams that are kind of used to that more waterfall centric way of working, there's a lot of, you know, frameworks that you can look to, to start to integrate and implement kind of components of agile across your different software, you know, your software development lifecycle, I guess, your software development process. And, you know, I can start with something small. That's, you know, an idea that we kind of recommend the teams, whether it's a new way of working, or it's a new process that you're implementing or maybe a new system to try to get to one of those end goals that you essentially have. Rather than having to go through this massive cultural
认证、你可以获得的认证，是有点愚蠢的。所以我想回答这个问题，对于那些习惯于那种更以瀑布为中心的工作方式的团队，有很多框架你可以参考，开始在你的不同软件开发生命周期，或者说你的软件开发流程中整合和实施敏捷的组件。而且，我可以从一些小事开始。这是一个我们向团队推荐的想法，无论是新的工作方式，还是你正在实施的新流程，或者也许是一个新的系统，试图达到你本质上拥有的那些最终目标之一。而不是必须经历这种巨大的文化
transformation of saying, we're no longer developing software like that. Everyone's got to work and organize in this way. I've seen that firsthand. It can be a very painful thing for an organization to have to go through. And so I guess to answer that question more directly, I would say, you know, start really with what your goals are in mind. And if you're switching from a way of working that is more waterfall centric to in wanting to be more agile, you know, really, what are you hoping to get out of that? And what does success look like for your team? And then find those frameworks or those processes that can overlap and get you closer towards that goal that feel comfortable for the team, that aren't necessarily transforming your entire process overnight or creating really confusing paradigm
转型，说：“我们不再那样开发软件了。每个人都必须以这种方式工作和组织。”我亲眼见过这种情况。对于一个组织来说，这可能是一件非常痛苦的事情。所以我想更直接地回答这个问题，我会说，真正从你的目标出发。如果你正在从一种更以瀑布为中心的工作方式转向想要变得更敏捷，你真正希望从中得到什么？对你的团队来说，成功是什么样子的？然后找到那些可以重叠并让你更接近该目标的框架或流程，这些框架或流程让团队感到舒适，而不一定是一夜之间改变你的整个流程，或者为组织中的人们创造非常令人困惑的范式
shifts for people in the organization to have to go through. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah. I mean, Patrick has a lot more experience on hardware- related things than I do, but I would imagine no matter what someone's working on, after a day of coding, there almost has to be some way to show that, even if it's just the person sitting next to you. And so in almost any environment, you can find that audience where you can get that immediate feedback. And then even if it's sort of just within your team or within your company or organization, you can be agile and then make those big strides when it gets pushed out to the
转变。是的，这完全说得通。是的。我的意思是，Patrick 在硬件相关方面比我有更多的经验，但我认为无论某人在做什么，在一天编码之后，几乎必须有一种方式来展示它，即使只是给坐在你旁边的人看。因此，在几乎任何环境中，你都可以找到那个可以获得即时反馈的受众。然后，即使它只是在你的团队内部或你的公司或组织内部，你也可以做到敏捷，然后在它被推送到
customer. For sure. Yeah. And I think, again, just kind of coming back to the idea of focusing on what your goals and what success looks like is a really important thing to think about as you're transitioning from any way of working to another way of working. I think if you only focus on the processes or the ways of working or the frameworks, you know, without really having any goal in mind, you just get disconnected from really what the purpose is behind agile and why it came to be kind of in the first place and why we move faster as organizations and why it matters to our customers. That, that makes sense. So, so, you know, folks who, so I guess, okay, so I'll ask kind of an initial question. Zenhub, do you, you provide this platform,
客户手中时取得那些巨大的进步。当然。而且我认为，再次回到关注你的目标和成功是什么样子的想法，这是你在从一种工作方式过渡到另一种工作方式时需要考虑的一个非常重要的事情。我认为如果你只关注流程、工作方式或框架，而没有真正考虑到任何目标，你就会与敏捷的真正目的、它最初产生的原因、我们作为组织为什么要更快地行动以及它为什么对我们的客户很重要脱节。这，这说得通。所以，所以，你知道，人们，所以我想，好吧，我会问一个初步的问题。ZenHub，你们提供这个平台，
but I'm assuming you also do a bit of sort of consulting if there's some, some folks who, who want to sort of improve their methodology in addition to using software. Yeah. So, oh, go ahead. No, I was just going to say, I spend a lot of my time on that. So it's, it's something that I'm pretty close to in the business. Oh, cool. So what do you find sort of changes when, when folks sort of adopt this, this methodology, like what,
但我假设如果有一些人想要在除了使用软件之外改进他们的方法论，你们也会做一些咨询。是的，所以，哦，请说。不，我只是想说，我花了很多时间在这上面。所以，这是我在业务中非常接近的事情。哦，酷。那么你发现当人们采用这种方法论时，通常会发生什么变化，比如，
what sort of like what's the impact of that? Yeah. I mean, hopefully the, the impact is, you know, that we're able to actually deliver value to customers sooner. Hopefully the whole team can be thinking through that lens rather than, okay, how do we just adopt the next thing? How do we ride that next wave of technology or that next wave of systems and process kind of thinking? Because, like I mentioned, at the core of it, we're really trying to deliver that value, you know, sooner. So what we typically see that, you know, teams go through these, these transformations, you know, is that the quality of what they're producing tends to
这种影响是什么？是的。我的意思是，希望这种影响是，我们能够真正更快地向客户交付价值。希望整个团队都能通过这个视角来思考，而不是“好吧，我们如何只是采用下一个东西？我们如何乘上那下一波技术浪潮或下一波系统和流程思维？”因为，正如我提到的，在它的核心，我们确实是在试图更快地交付价值。所以我们通常看到团队经历这些转型时，他们所生产的东西的质量往往会
increase the time, the market tends to decrease. The conceptualization of what a project is, or, you know, what a product is, tends to be much more of a minimum viable product and much more iterative. What I mean by that is instead of thinking, we have to ship the perfect product day one and get it right from the moment that it lands in our customers' hands, we can take a more iterative approach here because we're working in an agile way. We know that once we deliver something, we're not done. We have to come back to that. We have to get feedback on what we built. We build that back into the product. We look for opportunities to optimize in that. And so I think teams that are kind of going through those agile transformations or thinking about agile tend to think more in
提高，上市时间往往会缩短。对项目或产品是什么的构思，往往更倾向于“最小可行性产品”（MVP）和更具迭代性。我的意思是，与其认为我们必须在第一天就发布完美的产品，并从它落入客户手中的那一刻起就做对，我们可以采取一种更迭代的方法，因为我们是以敏捷的方式工作。我们知道，一旦我们交付了某些东西，我们并没有完成。我们必须回到它。我们必须对我们构建的东西获得反馈。我们将反馈纳入产品中。我们寻找优化它的机会。所以我认为正在经历这些敏捷转型或考虑敏捷的团队，往往会更多地以
those ways rather than here's a big project I have to deliver. This is the target delivery date for this. It has to be absolutely right from day one. And every feature has to be available in it from day one. You know, it can create these runaway projects where scope just increases and increases and increases. And you have this massive scope creep that happens versus people that are thinking in more agile ways, I think are naturally more attuned to saying, what is the maximum value that I can deliver in a first iteration, follow it up with, you know, subsequent iterations that keep on adding value to that product. And it's a pretty big mindset, mindset shift, depending on kind of where you're coming from. So yeah, that totally makes sense. So yeah, you have, you're in this
这些方式思考，而不是“这是一个我必须交付的大项目。这是它的目标交付日期。它必须从第一天起就绝对正确。而且每个功能都必须从第一天起就可用。”你知道，这会创造出这些失控的项目，范围不断增加。你会遇到这种巨大的“范围蔓延”（scope creep），而那些以更敏捷方式思考的人，我认为天生更倾向于说：“我在第一次迭代中能交付的最大价值是什么？”然后跟进后续的迭代，不断为该产品增加价值。这是一种非常大的思维方式转变，取决于你从哪里来。所以是的，这完全说得通。所以是的，你处于
sort of really unique position where you can, you, you literally are observing, let's say, split tests and back tests. So in other words, you have folks that switched from whatever they were doing, maybe it was something ad hoc or maybe it was a waterfall model to Agile. And you could also, if you're working with one part of a company and it's a larger company that has other software engineering teams, you can also split test and you can see what it's doing firsthand, which is really cool. I think it really gives you a unique perspective on Agile.
这种非常独特的位置，你可以观察，比如说，拆分测试和回测。换句话说，你有从他们正在做的任何事情（也许是临时的，也许是瀑布模型）切换到敏捷的人。而且，如果你正在与一家大公司的某一部分合作，而该公司还有其他软件工程团队，你也可以进行拆分测试，你可以亲眼看到它在做什么，这真的很酷。我认为这确实让你对敏捷有了独特的视角。
For sure. And I think one of the interesting things about that is that when companies, large organizations typically go through these transformations, it's typically not a, like you mentioned, a all or nothing approach where suddenly everyone wakes up one morning, there's an email in your inbox and it says, hey, we're now an agile shop and we're working in agile ways. You know, I mean, I hope it's not that, but there's, yeah. But typically there's teams that are piloting these new processes and piloting these new approaches and piloting the new tools and systems that come along with that. And more often than not, what we find within these large organizations is that it's not a mandate being pushed down from the CIO or from leadership saying, hey, you have to convert to an agile way of working.
当然。而且我认为关于这一点有趣的事情之一是，当公司，大型组织通常经历这些转型时，通常不是像你提到的那样，一种“全有或全无”的方法，即突然有一天早上每个人醒来，收件箱里有一封电子邮件，上面写着：“嘿，我们现在是一家敏捷商店，我们正在以敏捷方式工作。”我的意思是，我希望不是那样，但有，是的。但通常会有团队在试点这些新流程，试点这些新方法，并试点随之而来的新工具和系统。而且我们发现，在这些大型组织中，更多时候，这不是来自 CIO 或领导层的强制命令，说：“嘿，你们必须转换为敏捷的工作方式。”
Oftentimes within the organization, and funny enough, it's teams that are looking at the parts of the organization that adopted Agile and saying, holy, man, are they moving faster than we are? Or, wow, look at how much better they're able to build and deliver software. We need to start working like that. And so that groundswell of adoption tends to come more bottoms up, I think, than you'd expect in a lot of organizations because people see the results and people see the dynamic and the change that actually happens when you start working in agile ways. And that's been really fun to see as well, because you can start with a really small team, you know, that's adopting your solution. And then before you know it, you have people knocking on your
通常在组织内部，有趣的是，是那些看着组织中采用敏捷的部分的团队在说：“天哪，他们比我们行动得快吗？或者，哇，看看他们能够多好地构建和交付软件。我们需要开始那样工作。”因此，这种采用的浪潮往往比你在许多组织中预期的更倾向于自下而上，因为人们看到了结果，人们看到了当你开始以敏捷方式工作时实际发生的动态和变化。看到这一点也非常有趣，因为你可以从一个采用你们解决方案的非常小的团队开始。然后在你意识到之前，你就有人们敲你的
door saying, we want to use this thing because we want to be more like that other team, or we see the value in doing this, like let us in. So I think that's a really cool aspect of it, too. That's super cool. One thing is a bit of a bit of a tangent. But I've noticed a lot of it's very hard to build things for engineers because because they tend to want to build everything themselves. It's like, this only solves 99.69% of the problem. I need to build it from scratch. Right. And so, and so, you know, but GitHub runs counter to that. I mean, GitHub is amazing and Zen Hub runs counter to that. And so how, how are you able to, you know, kind of get, get folks to adopt Zen Hub instead of hacking something together and pick any web framework
门说：“我们想使用这个东西，因为我们想变得像那个团队一样，或者我们看到了这样做的好处，让我们加入吧。”所以我认为这也是它非常酷的一个方面。这太酷了。有一件事有点跑题。但我注意到，为工程师构建东西非常困难，因为他们往往想自己构建一切。就像，“这只解决了 99.69% 的问题。我需要从头开始构建它。”对吧。所以，而且，你知道，但 GitHub 与此背道而驰。我的意思是，GitHub 很棒，Zen Hub 也与此背道而驰。所以，你是如何能够，你知道，让人们采用 Zen Hub 而不是拼凑一些东西并选择任何他们想要的 Web 框架
they want? Yeah, I think it's an interesting question. There's a couple of ways that we think about that. One is kind of extensibility and flexibility of our product. And so we've been very intentional in saying, we don't want to take the most opinionated approach in the market and say, here's our tool, you have to use it, then the engineers get upset and they go, well, we have to customize it and it's not fit for our purpose. So we're going to have to rewrite another one or we're going to have to rebuild this whole thing from scratch. We actually try to provide enough flexibility within our product that if you're used to a certain way of working or you want to try other ways of working, it's easy to actually customize
的？是的，我认为这是一个有趣的问题。我们有几种思考方式。一是我们产品的可扩展性和灵活性。所以我们非常有意识地说，我们不想在市场上采取最武断的方法，说：“这是我们的工具，你必须使用它。”然后工程师们会感到不安，他们会说：“好吧，我们必须定制它，它不适合我们的目的。所以我们将不得不重写另一个，或者我们将不得不从头开始重建整个东西。”我们实际上试图在我们的产品中提供足够的灵活性，以便如果你习惯于某种工作方式，或者你想尝试其他工作方式，很容易实际定制
and configure the product for that. And so hopefully that alleviates the need for engineers to feel like they need to go off and create a separate system themselves to do that. The other thing is that we do provide a pretty extensible API around our product as well. So there aren't features or things that you can do inside of Zen Hub. We try to create a really accessible way to get that information either outside of the system or to put that information into the system. So hopefully, if it's not a use case that we've thought of or something that we've kind of built into the product, you can actually go and build that yourself. And I feel like a lot of engineers actually appreciate that approach. And that kind
和配置产品。所以希望这减轻了工程师觉得他们需要离开并自己创建一个单独系统来做这件事的需要。另一件事是，我们也确实围绕我们的产品提供了一个非常可扩展的 API。所以，如果你在 Zen Hub 内部没有功能或事情可以做，我们试图创造一种非常可访问的方式来获取系统之外的信息，或者将该信息放入系统中。所以希望，如果这不是我们想到的用例，或者不是我们构建到产品中的东西，你实际上可以去自己构建它。而且我觉得很多工程师实际上很欣赏这种方法。而且这
of alleviates, I think, a little bit of that feeling to be like, well, this tool isn't what I need, so I need to go off and build it. The other thing I would say, too, is just culturally reminding teams of what your mission is, and even individual developers. Publicly, we can talk about a customer we work with. It's a really exciting use case. It's the Jet Propulsion Labs team that's part of NASA that actually uses our product. You know, when you're a developer there, your mission is to, you know, be putting spacecraft on the moon and be putting spacecraft on Mars. And that's what incentivized you to go and work
减轻了，我认为，一点那种感觉，即“好吧，这个工具不是我需要的，所以我需要离开并构建它。”我还会说，另一件事就是文化上提醒团队你的使命是什么，甚至是个人开发者。公开地，我们可以谈论一个我们合作的客户。这是一个非常令人兴奋的用例。那是 NASA 下属的喷气推进实验室（Jet Propulsion Labs）团队，他们实际上使用了我们的产品。你知道，当你是一名那里的开发者时，你的使命是，你知道，将航天器送上月球，将航天器送上火星。这就是激励你去
for Jet Propulsion Labs of all the cool things that you need to do, not building tooling and infrastructure, you know, to solve the problems in the organization. So there's that constant kind of reminder sometimes for people too, in terms of, Hey, like, you know, we need your feedback and be open and vocal about it because your mission and your job, your mission actually quite literally is to, to go off and do this, you know, space related thing, not to build the best in class project management tool. So let us take that on, give us your feedback, tell us, you know, what you need in the product. We'll do our best to build it in.
为喷气推进实验室工作的所有你需要做的酷事，而不是构建工具和基础设施，你知道，来解决组织中的问题。所以有时人们也会有那种持续的提醒，即：“嘿，我们需要你的反馈，要开放并大声说出来，因为你的使命和你的工作，你的使命实际上相当字面上是去完成这个，你知道，与太空相关的事情，而不是构建一流的项目管理工具。”所以让我们承担这一点，给我们你的反馈，告诉我们，你知道，你在产品中需要什么。我们会尽力将其构建进去。
And if we can't, we'll make our experience extensible enough, hopefully, so that you can build it yourself. Yeah, that totally, totally makes sense. And so did that, was that realized on day one? So on day, like early in Zen Hub, did you say, you know, we're, this product is for engineers, it needs to have a really solid API, or is that something you kind of learned along the way? I think it's definitely something we learned along the way. Um, the origin story for Zenhub is, is a really different one. And it doesn't really follow the typical narrative of starting a company where, you know, there was, uh, two engineers at Google that were frustrated by X and they went out and got built it. And then
如果我们不能，我们会让我们的体验足够可扩展，希望如此，这样你就可以自己构建它。是的，这完全、完全说得通。所以，这是在第一天就实现的吗？所以，在 Zen Hub 的早期，你们是否说：“你知道，我们，这个产品是为工程师准备的，它需要有一个非常坚实的 API”，还是这是你们在过程中学到的东西？我认为这绝对是我们在此过程中学到的东西。嗯，Zenhub 的起源故事非常不同。它并没有真正遵循创办公司的典型叙事，即你知道，有两名谷歌工程师对 X 感到沮丧，他们出去构建了它。然后
we raised funding for it. And now, you know, we're, you know, kind of taking over the world. We really just noticed, and this was back when I was working at Axiom Zen, that kind of parent company of Zen Hub, that the way we were building software was just fundamentally broken in a couple of really important ways. And we noticed that our developers were constantly spending, you know, all of their time almost inside of github and that was the environment where they were most comfortable with it was the environment where they felt most at home but we were constantly forcing them outside of that to go and update these different project management tools because as a business we needed to know where we were at
我们为它筹集了资金。现在，你知道，我们正在，你知道，接管世界。我们只是注意到，这还是我在 Axiom Zen（Zen Hub 的母公司）工作时，我们构建软件的方式在几个非常重要的方面从根本上被破坏了。我们注意到我们的开发者不断地花费，你知道，他们几乎所有的时间都在 github 内部，那是他们最舒服的环境，是他们感到最自在的环境，但我们不断地强迫他们离开那里去更新这些不同的项目管理工具，因为作为一家企业，我们需要知道我们处于什么位置
you know we were working with customers and clients at the time, and we needed to have that lens into these different software development efforts. I just had this crazy sort of out-of-body experience because I'm literally going through that right now where we spend almost all of our time in GitHub, but our project management is using Google Docs. Yeah. And it's such a high friction experience, right? Yeah, totally. Developers who are used to that environment, you're saying once a day or multiple times a day, come out of that environment where you're most comfortable into this other project management tool to update what you're working on simply so that we can report that to someone else
你知道，我们当时正在与客户和客户合作，我们需要对这些不同的软件开发工作有那种视角。我刚才有一种疯狂的灵魂出窍体验，因为我确实正在经历那个过程，我们几乎所有的时间都花在 GitHub 上，但我们的项目管理使用的是 Google Docs。是的。这是一种摩擦力很大的体验，对吧？是的，完全。习惯于那种环境的开发者，你说一天一次或多次，离开你最舒服的环境进入这个其他项目管理工具来更新你正在做的事情，仅仅是为了我们可以向其他人报告
or have an accurate view of the project. And what tends to happen more often than not, and I'm not sure if this has been your experience too, is that developers don't do it. You know, they have other important things to do and it's an extra added hassle and kind of headache at the end of the day to have to remember that. The challenge there though is no one really wants to make developers' lives more difficult. It's the fact that project managers need access to that information, hopefully in an accurate way to actually provide visibility and transparency further up. And when they don't have a system that's up to date, they ultimately don't have accurate information. So that's really the problem that we were trying to solve. And what was broken with
或者对项目有一个准确的看法。而往往发生的情况是，我不确定这是否也是你的经历，是开发者不这样做。你知道，他们还有其他重要的事情要做，而且在一天结束时，记住这一点是一种额外的麻烦和头痛。然而，这里的挑战是，没有人真正想让开发者的生活变得更困难。事实是，项目经理需要访问这些信息，希望以准确的方式，以便实际提供可见性和透明度。当他们没有一个最新的系统时，他们最终就没有准确的信息。所以这确实是我们试图解决的问题。而我们的流程中被破坏的是
our process is that whenever you'd ask a project manager how this particular project was doing, no one really had a clue because we were using systems that our developers wouldn't really keep up to date. And so that really led us down that path of saying, what if we just built this thing over top of the source code layer? What if we just integrated as deeply as possible as we could with where developers are already spending their time? And so you talk about, what would you guys think about APIs and think about extensibility upfront. Literally the first version of Zen Hub was a hacky Chrome extension that actually manipulated the GitHub DOM. I'm not sure how we even made it past those early days sometimes too, because we were literally injecting code into GitHub's website, but to inject this tab where you could actually have a task board to manage all your issues and pull requests. And that was kind of the MVP of the product and just being kind of that
每当你问项目经理这个特定项目进展如何时，没有人真正有头绪，因为我们使用的系统我们的开发者并不会真正保持更新。所以这确实引导我们走上了那条路，说：“如果我们只是在源代码层之上构建这个东西会怎样？如果我们尽可能深入地与开发者已经花费时间的地方集成会怎样？”所以你谈到，你们在前期对 API 和可扩展性的看法。字面上，Zen Hub 的第一个版本是一个黑客 Chrome 扩展，它实际上操作了 GitHub DOM。我有时甚至不知道我们是如何度过那些早期的，因为我们实际上是在向 GitHub 的网站注入代码，但为了注入这个标签页，你实际上可以有一个任务板来管理你所有的议题和拉取请求。而这就是产品的 MVP，只是作为那种
very physical experience inside of GitHub. Not a lot of automation in that, fairly manual, but we noticed in using it that our process really just changed completely overnight. And as we started to get more traction and get more developers on the product, that's when we started really thinking about, okay, well, how do we build this in a way that kind of, I guess, best fits with that? And I still think it's a pretty core differentiator for us today because what we always come back to,
在 GitHub 内部是一种非常实体的体验。其中并没有太多的自动化，相当于是手动的，但我们在使用过程中注意到，我们的流程几乎在一夜之间就彻底改变了。随着我们开始获得更多关注并吸引更多开发者使用该产品，我们开始真正思考：好吧，我们该如何以一种最契合这种方式的方法来构建它呢？直到今天，我仍然认为这是我们一个非常核心的差异化优势，因为我们总是会回归到一点，
you know, is we're looking at new features and looking at new things we can build and taking in customer feedback is what is the developer experience and how is that going to impact that? And that developer love i think that we have in the product today so uh the initial version you said sort of like did some you know uh dom injection but uh how do you how do you what do you do now it seems like that's necessary right if you're going to integrate with someone else's website yeah well i mean, that totally became the model, right?
你知道，当我们审视新功能、构思可以构建的新事物并采纳客户反馈时，我们关注的是开发者体验，以及它将如何影响这种体验。我认为这就是我们产品目前所拥有的“开发者之爱”。那么，你刚才提到最初的版本做了一些，你知道，DOM 注入，但你们现在是怎么做的？如果你要与别人的网站集成，这似乎是必要的，对吧？是的，我的意思是，这完全成了我们的模式，对吧？
And at first, like I said, it was just like, well, how do we physically stay inside of the GitHub UI? Because that's where people are comfortable with. And we want to be able to work from github.com. We don't want to have to manage a separate platform and have to manage separate logins and authentications for a lot of that. And so half of that, I think, was made from the choice of,
起初，就像我说的，我们只是在想，我们如何才能物理性地留在 GitHub 的界面内？因为那是人们感到舒适的地方。我们希望能够直接在 github.com 上工作。我们不想管理一个单独的平台，也不想为其中的很多功能去管理单独的登录和身份验证。所以我想，这其中有一半的决定是基于，
this is literally the best experience for the developers. Half of that was like, half of that, I think, was made from the choice of, this is literally the best experience for the developers. Half of that was like, here are some freebies we can get by integrating with GitHub OAuth and integrating into their platform. It's still fairly core to our strategy today, but I would say the one thing that changed, and this is something I think for anyone listening that is a fairly typical situation, is that software development, especially for commercial projects, but also in open source and also larger projects,
这确实是开发者最好的体验。而另一半，我想，是基于这样一个选择：通过集成 GitHub OAuth 并接入他们的平台，我们可以获得一些免费的便利。这在今天仍然是我们战略的核心，但我认为有一点发生了变化，而且我认为对于任何听众来说，这都是一个相当典型的情况，那就是软件开发，特别是商业项目，但也包括开源项目和大型项目，
it truly does become a team sport at some level. And it's not just about developers off working on code and building things. It's the coordination that needs to happen around that and the surfacing of that visibility to the rest of the organization. And so that's when we also started to think about the experience from the perspective of the other personas that are involved in building software, whether it's a design team that's actually creating the design spec for what is going to be built, whether it's a product team that's coordinating and gathering requirements, whether it's a project manager that's organizing the work into sprints, whether it's a QA manager that's actively kind of testing and doing a lot of QA on the work.
在某种程度上确实变成了一项团队运动。这不仅仅是开发者在编写代码和构建东西。这还需要围绕这些工作进行协调，并将这种可见性呈现给组织的其他成员。因此，我们也开始从参与软件构建的其他角色的角度来思考这种体验，无论是实际创建构建设计规范的设计团队，还是协调和收集需求的产品团队，亦或是将工作组织成冲刺（sprints）的项目经理，还是积极进行测试和质量保证的 QA 经理。
And so that's when we really started to think about our experience, at least from the perspective of different personas that would come into contact with that. And we've actually built outside of the extension and started to kind of layer different areas or different value into different areas of the product since then. But yeah, it's evolved a lot from just that initial way of thinking at initial product. So yeah, that totally makes sense. Totally makes sense. Like you don't, it's sort of the same issue in reverse. You don't want the project manager now to have to live in GitHub. You have sort of a separate user experience and they share like a common backend. Exactly. Yeah. And believe me, we found that out very quickly that project managers are
所以，我们开始真正从接触这些工作的不同角色的角度来思考我们的体验。从那时起，我们实际上已经跳出了扩展程序的范畴，开始在产品的不同领域叠加不同的价值。但确实，它已经从最初的思维方式和最初的产品演变了很多。所以，这完全说得通。完全说得通。就像你说的，这有点像是反过来的问题。你现在不想让项目经理必须生活在 GitHub 里。你们有一种单独的用户体验，但它们共享一个通用的后端。没错。是的，相信我，我们很快就发现项目经理们
not necessarily at home inside of GitHub. And that was kind of that moment of realization of like, well, we built an awesome tool here that has an amazing developer experience, but man, now there's a lot of other people that are coming into contact with this. We need to give them that information in a venue and in a place where they feel comfortable as well. So we actually built our own web app container with Zenhub as well. It tends to be that if you're a developer, you're using GitHub, you love to stay inside
并不一定习惯待在 GitHub 内部。那是一个顿悟的时刻，就像是：好吧，我们在这里构建了一个很棒的工具，拥有惊人的开发者体验，但是天哪，现在有许多其他人也在接触它。我们需要在一个让他们感到舒适的场所和位置为他们提供这些信息。所以我们实际上也为 Zenhub 构建了自己的 Web 应用容器。通常情况下，如果你是开发者，你正在使用 GitHub，你喜欢待在
that view, you'll download our extension and actually use Zenhub inside the GitHub platform. As a project manager or product owner, maybe you're using the web app which is available kind of on any browser regardless of whether or not extensions are supported it's available on any device and so just much more of a home for that persona but yeah it was it was kind of funny going through that realization of being like we have fantastic traction with developers they love using the tool and then it was started getting a lot of pushback fairly quickly from people being like, so I signed up for GitHub the other day and couldn't figure out where I was supposed to go. And it's like, I don't know the last time you guys went through the onboarding for GitHub, but it's so developer focused. And it's like, create your first PR.
那个视图里，你会下载我们的扩展程序，并在 GitHub 平台内使用 Zenhub。作为项目经理或产品负责人，也许你会使用 Web 应用，它可以在任何浏览器上使用，无论是否支持扩展程序，它在任何设备上都可用，所以对那个角色来说，这更像是一个家。但确实，经历那种顿悟时刻挺有趣的，就像是：我们吸引了大量的开发者，他们喜欢使用这个工具，然后很快就开始收到很多人的反馈，说：“我前几天注册了 GitHub，但不知道该去哪里。” 就像是，我不知道你们上次经历 GitHub 的新手引导是什么时候，但它太专注于开发者了。就像是，“创建你的第一个 PR”。
And project managers would be like, why? That seems like a dangerous thing to do, actually. And we were like, yeah, that is actually a dangerous thing to do. Don't go off and create PRs against the repos where you've been given access to these stuff. Yeah, right. Totally. Very cool. And I guess there's maybe even like a leadership. That might be part of the app, I guess. So leaders can see the breakdown of many different agile teams. Yeah, that's kind of been the next part in the journey for us. And I think we think about where we go as a company a lot through the lens of these personas.
项目经理会说：“为什么？这看起来是一件危险的事情。” 我们当时就说：“是的，这确实是一件危险的事情。不要在你被授予访问权限的仓库里随意创建 PR。” 是的，没错。完全正确。太酷了。我想可能甚至还有一个领导层视角。我想那可能是应用的一部分。这样领导者就可以看到许多不同敏捷团队的细分情况。是的，这对我们来说是旅程的下一部分。我认为我们作为一家公司，很多时候是通过这些角色的视角来思考我们未来的方向。
I think it's a useful way for anyone that's actually listening to this and either building software or thinking about building software to think about your product vision and to think about how you actually set vision for where you want to go is to think about the personas and jobs to be done of the people who are interacting with your product. Obviously, I think we provide a best-in-class experience for developers. We integrate to the source code layer. We get out of your way. We provide just enough value at the right time for the project manager.
我认为对于任何正在听这个节目、正在构建软件或考虑构建软件的人来说，这是一种有用的方式来思考你的产品愿景，以及思考你如何为想要达到的目标设定愿景，那就是思考与你的产品交互的人员的角色和待办任务。显然，我认为我们为开发者提供了同类中最好的体验。我们集成到源代码层。我们不会妨碍你。我们为项目经理在正确的时间提供恰到好处的价值。
One of the personas that we're kind of focusing on now is, how do we present a lot of this insight, and a lot of what's happening in the software development organization, up to leadership? And take what's being done by the developers organization up to leadership and take what's being done by the developers and start to connect that back to what the business actually cares about and where we're ultimately going as a company. So if we're calling out these big initiatives that we're going through, these new products we want to build, these new features within products that we want to build, connecting
我们现在关注的角色之一是：我们如何将这些洞察力，以及软件开发组织中正在发生的大量事情，呈现给领导层？将开发者组织所做的事情提升到领导层，并将开发者所做的事情与业务真正关心的内容以及我们作为公司最终要达到的目标联系起来。所以，如果我们正在提出我们正在进行的这些重大举措，我们想要构建的这些新产品，我们想要构建的产品内的新功能，将
the work that developers are doing inside of GitHub to those major projects I think is a pretty big gap that not a lot of organizations have a great answer for. And being able to do that with what's actually happening in the source code is so powerful because ultimately the view that you're seeing into your projects is coming directly from the changes that are happening in your code base rather than people manually updating them. So we actually launched a brand new feature just at the beginning of November, actually, called Zen Hub Roadmaps to essentially allow teams to build product roadmaps directly inside of Zen Hub.
开发者在 GitHub 内部所做的工作与这些重大项目联系起来，我认为这是一个很大的缺口，很多组织都没有很好的答案。能够利用源代码中实际发生的事情来做到这一点是非常强大的，因为最终你看到的项目视图直接来自于代码库中发生的变更，而不是人们手动更新它们。所以我们实际上在 11 月初刚刚发布了一个全新的功能，叫做 Zen Hub Roadmaps，本质上是允许团队直接在 Zen Hub 内部构建产品路线图。
And then for the items in that roadmap to be connected back down to the individual issues and pull requests that are being worked on by different teams. And it's been a really cool layer of visibility. And like you said, we see a lot of teams use that to really surface what is happening in the engineering organization to the rest of the business and to leadership as well. That's awesome. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Hey, guys, I'm going to jump in for a minute here with a word from this episode's sponsor. We're happy again to have Educative.io uh an online learning resource and since the last time we
然后将路线图中的项目连接回不同团队正在处理的单个议题（issues）和拉取请求（pull requests）。这是一种非常酷的可见性层。就像你说的，我们看到很多团队利用它来真正向业务的其他部门和领导层展示工程组织中正在发生的事情。太棒了。是的，这完全说得通。嘿，伙计们，我要插播一分钟，介绍一下本期节目的赞助商。我们很高兴再次邀请到 Educative.io，一个在线学习资源平台，自上次我们
came to you talking about them they've changed things up a little they have a brand new option instead of buying courses one by one and selecting what you want they now offer they still offer that but they also offer the ability to get a subscription where you can for the length of your subscription access any of the courses so all the same courses we talked about before you can now access for sort of a flat monthly or you know per time period fee and because of their sponsorship they've agreed to give us at educative.io slash programming throwdown 10 off either a single month's purchase or the subscription that's right you get 10 off pretty much anything in the store so so i was looking at the courses after we talked last time and um a couple things that i i guess i missed and which is one is they
向你们介绍他们以来，他们做了一些改变。他们有一个全新的选项，而不是一个一个地购买课程并选择你想要的，他们现在提供——他们仍然提供那种方式，但他们也提供订阅服务，在订阅期间，你可以访问任何课程。所以我们之前谈到的所有课程，你现在都可以通过一种固定的月费或按时间段付费的方式来访问。因为他们的赞助，他们同意在 educative.io/programmingthrowdown 上为我们提供 10% 的折扣，无论是单月购买还是订阅。没错，商店里几乎所有东西你都能获得 10% 的折扣。所以，上次我们谈完之后，我看了看他们的课程，嗯，有几件事我猜我错过了，其中之一是他们
have a number of courses that are actually just completely free if you want to try them. So they have free previews, you know, little parts of many of their courses, but they also have a number of languages from scratch. So C++ and Python from scratch. And those courses are actually free. So not only are they a great way to learn or advance your knowledge in those languages, but it's a great way to actually check out the platform first because spending any money, I mean, I don't like spending money. So not spending money and still being able to check something out
有很多课程实际上是完全免费的，如果你想尝试的话。所以他们有免费预览，你知道，他们许多课程的一小部分，但他们也有许多从零开始的语言课程。比如 C++ 和 Python 从零开始。这些课程实际上是免费的。所以它们不仅是学习或提升这些语言知识的好方法，而且也是首先体验该平台的好方法，因为花钱，我的意思是，我不喜欢花钱。所以不用花钱还能体验一下
always alleviates a little bit of the sort of nervousness around doing it. And this is a great way to check out the platform, these from scratch courses. And there's also another course I found on here that's the practicing for programming interviews. So Jason, you do interviews at your company. Do you recommend people practice programming before they show up to your interview? Yeah, totally. The cool thing about this is,
总是能减轻一点对尝试新事物的紧张感。这是一个体验平台的好方法，这些从零开始的课程。我还在这里发现了另一门课程，是关于编程面试练习的。所以 Jason，你在你的公司进行面试。你建议人们在参加你的面试之前练习编程吗？是的，完全建议。这个东西很酷的地方在于，
is, you know, when you're kind of writing in this sort of environment, they kind of give you some, they kind of give you some setup, and then you you some setup and then you write some code and then you can even kind of, you know, validate that you've done the right thing. And that's that kind of loop of, you know, writing something, especially, you know, in this case, if you're, unless you're sort of using an editor and then coming back, but if you're, but if you're writing it in the editor, you know, you, you're kind of writing that as if you're writing it on a whiteboard. And then you're getting this instant feedback like, OK, you got it right. You need to try again. And that's really going to kind of give you that muscle memory that you need so that when you go to a whiteboard interview, you kind of are a little bit more prepared. I think that the from scratch
你知道，当你在这种环境中编写代码时，他们会给你一些设置，然后你编写一些代码，甚至可以验证你是否做对了。那种循环，你知道，编写一些东西，特别是，你知道，在这种情况下，除非你是在使用编辑器然后回来，但如果你是在编辑器中编写它，你知道，你编写它的方式就像你在白板上写一样。然后你会得到这种即时的反馈，比如：“好的，你做对了。你需要再试一次。” 这真的会给你提供你所需要的肌肉记忆，这样当你去参加白板面试时，你会准备得更充分一些。我认为这些从零开始的
courses are really solid. And the other part of it is, you know, it's, it's a different way to learn, you know, there, there might be some folks out there who can do sort of the lecture thing. For me, it's, it's, it never really resonated with me. Something like this where it's hands-on is, is, is really good for, for people like me. And it's, it's, it's awesome that they have this free course. So even if you're you know a python guru um but but you think this might be a good way to learn something else uh you know you could dive through the python course you could pick a different language and dive through that uh totally for free and then if that looks like the kind of you know learning model that's really going to work for you um you
课程真的很扎实。另一部分是，你知道，这是一种不同的学习方式，你知道，外面可能有一些人可以接受那种讲座式的学习。对我来说，它从来没有真正引起我的共鸣。像这样亲自动手的学习方式，对像我这样的人来说真的很好。而且他们有这个免费课程真是太棒了。所以即使你是一个 Python 大师，但你认为这可能是一个学习其他东西的好方法，你知道，你可以深入学习 Python 课程，你可以选择一门不同的语言并深入学习，完全免费。然后如果这看起来是你真正适用的学习模式，嗯，你
know that you kind of know that without having to spend any money they didn't really i was trying to think about it i guess when i was learning a program i mostly did it from like books before even really like getting on the internet or there being internet i mean i guess there probably was but we didn't really use it um so the closest i could think of this was did you ever do vim tutor no i didn't oh so if you ever you know have accessed vim one of the things that will reckon or I guess VI is the same thing. I'm not really good about the difference between the two. So if you open them, sometimes the bottom would be like, I forget there's some command you can type and it will basically walk you through like a document, which also tells
知道，你不用花钱就能知道这一点。他们没有真的，我当时在想，我猜我在学习编程时，在真正上网或互联网普及之前，我主要是通过书本学习的。我的意思是，我猜当时可能已经有互联网了，但我们并没有真正使用它。所以我想到的最接近的东西是，你有没有用过 vim tutor？没有，我没有。哦，所以如果你曾经访问过 vim，其中一件会推荐的事情，或者我猜 VI 也是一样的。我不太清楚两者之间的区别。所以如果你打开它们，有时底部会显示，我忘了你可以输入什么命令，它基本上会引导你完成一个文档，它也会告诉你
you like how to edit and you like move up and down in the document. And it's sort of almost like kind of like interactive fiction about learning how to use vim oh yeah emacs has something similar oh okay uh and i was thinking like actually this kind of is like that but you know of course like a hundred times better or whatever but yeah you know when you originally said that i thought you were thinking about um they actually used to have these um i keep wanting to say choose your own adventure. They're about the same form factor as those choose your own adventure books. But it's not, you read it, you know, left to right. But you get to a point and there's basically like a little puzzle. And, you know, you're supposed to like solve the puzzle.
如何编辑，以及如何在文档中上下移动。这几乎就像是关于学习如何使用 vim 的互动小说。哦，是的，emacs 也有类似的东西。哦，好的。我当时在想，实际上这有点像那样，但你知道，当然比那个好一百倍什么的。但确实，你知道，当你最初说那个的时候，我以为你在想，嗯，他们实际上过去有这些，嗯，我一直想说“选择你自己的冒险”。它们的格式和那些“选择你自己的冒险”书差不多。但不是，你从左到右阅读。但你到了一个点，基本上有一个小谜题。而且，你知道，你应该解决这个谜题。
And then somehow there's some way to like validate you got it right. And then you keep reading and so the idea is you have to it's kind of on the honor system but but you would um you'd be reading this is just like a paperback book and then it would be like oh put in this basic code and then and then edit it to solve the puzzle and that's basically how i got started yeah so i mean i think this you know format is you know obviously catching on in a lot of different places. And it's really awesome to see. This is a learning resource, I think is really resonate with people, the ability to be able to be almost anywhere and be able to interactively, you know, read, write the code, not necessarily just like listening to a lecture and trying to figure out like, how do I make it go 50% faster? How fast can I go before I can't understand the person anymore? Not that I've ever done that before. But yeah, I think this is a great forum for learning. Yeah, this is awesome, guys. Check it out. Educative.io slash programming throwdown. That's going to get you a 10% discount.
然后以某种方式验证你做对了。然后你继续阅读，所以这个想法是，你必须，这有点像是在荣誉系统上，但你会，你会阅读，这就像一本平装书，然后它会说，哦，输入这个基础代码，然后编辑它来解决谜题，这就是我入门的方式。是的，所以我的意思是，我认为这种格式显然在很多不同的地方流行起来。看到这一点真的很棒。这是一个学习资源，我认为它真的能引起人们的共鸣，能够几乎在任何地方，并且能够互动地，你知道，阅读、编写代码，而不一定只是听讲座并试图弄清楚，比如，我怎么让它快 50%？在我听不懂那个人说话之前，我能走多快？并不是说我以前做过那种事。但确实，我认为这是一个很好的学习论坛。是的，这太棒了，伙计们。去看看吧。Educative.io/programmingthrowdown。这会给你 10% 的折扣。
That's also going to let them know that, you know, that this was a good slot for them, that they were a good sponsor for us. So that helps us out. It also helps you out. And check it out. Also, let us know. Send us comments. Send us email. Let us know what you think of the courses. And we can relay that back to the folks at Educative and give them feedback so they can keep improving.
这也会让他们知道，你知道，这是一个很好的广告位，他们对我们来说是一个很好的赞助商。所以这对我们有帮助。这对你也有帮助。去看看吧。另外，让我们知道。给我们评论。给我们发电子邮件。让我们知道你对这些课程的看法。我们可以把这些反馈转达给 Educative 的伙伴们，让他们不断改进。
All right. Thanks for the sponsorship. And let's get back to interviewing. All right. Spiraling back up a bit. So yeah, you know, if someone just wants to get started with agile, I mean, actually, this is something that agile took me personally a long time to get into. And I think it's because when you search for agile, what you find is just a lot of different names of processes. And actually, you know, it reminds me a lot of the, like, Lean Six Sigma. You know, like the black belt. Yeah, I remember that.
好的。感谢赞助。让我们回到采访中。好的。稍微回溯一下。所以是的，你知道，如果有人想开始使用敏捷，我的意思是，实际上，这是敏捷让我个人花了很多时间才进入的东西。我认为这是因为当你搜索敏捷时，你找到的只是很多不同的流程名称。实际上，你知道，它让我想起了很多精益六西格玛（Lean Six Sigma）。你知道，比如黑带。是的，我记得那个。
Yeah. So it's kind of, it's kind of, it's pretty nebulous. You know, you don't, when you search for, you know, agile programming, you don't get, you just get all the information at once. Yeah. So if someone wants to, let's say someone's a, you know, a student, maybe they're a PhD student and they have pretty long projects, you know, projects that could take years, but they're working, let's say by themselves or with a couple of people you know what is something
是的。所以它有点，它有点，它相当模糊。你知道，当你搜索，你知道，敏捷编程时，你得不到，你只是立刻得到了所有的信息。是的。所以如果有人想，假设有人是一个，你知道，学生，也许他们是一个博士生，他们有相当长的项目，你知道，可能需要几年时间的项目，但他们是独自工作，或者和几个人一起工作，你知道，有什么是
that that that they can do um that would sort of you know get them get them the right mental model yeah that they can dive into agile i think it's really funny you mentioned like lean six sigma because i i remember and i just have this like flashback of of uh you know me in high school and and uh was actually like trying to understand and like read about that. I thought it would be something that would be like really big. And then, like you said, you go out and you search all this, not to say that it isn't big and isn't well adopted, but, um, you go out and you search for like all of this to try to figure out like, this is a topic I've heard a lot about, or I've read a lot about, or keeps on coming up. And then everything talks about supply chain management logistics. And you're like, I don't
他们可以做的，嗯，能让他们，你知道，获得正确的思维模型，是的，他们可以深入研究敏捷。我认为你提到精益六西格玛真的很搞笑，因为我记得，我脑海中闪过一个画面，关于，你知道，我在高中的时候，实际上是在试图理解并阅读关于那个的东西。我以为那会是一个非常大的东西。然后，就像你说的，你出去搜索所有这些，并不是说它不大，也不是说它没有被很好地采用，但是，嗯，你出去搜索所有这些，试图弄清楚，这是一个我听说过很多，或者读过很多，或者不断出现的话题。然后所有东西都在谈论供应链管理物流。然后你会想，我不
know supply chain management logistics. Like I'm in high school. I just want to know how to do things more efficiently. And like, you know, it seems like a cool area and field to kind of study. And agile is kind of the same way, right? Where you search it, like you said, and then you're seeing all this stuff around, like the methodologies, the frameworks and the tools and like, and then you get into really complicated parts of it too, like safe, which is scaled agile framework. And it's like the release train
懂供应链管理物流。就像我在上高中。我只是想知道如何更有效地做事。而且，你知道，这看起来是一个很酷的领域和方向去研究。敏捷也是一样，对吧？你搜索它，就像你说的，然后你看到所有关于方法论、框架和工具的东西，然后你也会进入非常复杂的领域，比如 SAFE，也就是规模化敏捷框架（Scaled Agile Framework）。就像发布火车
and program increments. And you're like, stop, I am done. Like I can't, I can't learn this anymore. And so if you're completely new to agile, if you're a student, you know, in high school, or if you're doing your undergrad, or if you're doing your PhD, you know, what I would recommend is starting with some of the basics to familiarize yourself with that. There's three resources I think that come to mind that I can call out that I think are pretty powerful for that. The first is starting with the Agile Manifesto. This was written a while ago, but if you're not familiar with what it is, it really spells out a lot of the core tenets of what it means to be agile and really why this way of thinking kind of came about and what it was trying to kind of work against. And I think it's really a good read. It's a short one too.
和项目增量。然后你会说，停，我受够了。我不能，我不能再学这个了。所以如果你对敏捷完全陌生，如果你是一个学生，你知道，在高中的时候，或者如果你正在读本科，或者如果你正在读博士，你知道，我会建议从一些基础知识开始，让自己熟悉它。我想到了三个资源，我认为我可以提出来，我认为这对那方面非常强大。首先是从《敏捷宣言》（Agile Manifesto）开始。这是很久以前写的，但如果你不熟悉它是什么，它确实阐明了敏捷的核心原则，以及为什么这种思维方式会产生，以及它试图反对什么。我认为这是一本很好的读物。它也很短。
And there's just kind of four core points and then I think 12 points on the actual manifesto itself. But it's a good read to create perspective around the intentions behind agile. And when these people kind of came together and developed this way of thinking what it was kind of meant to address um and i think you know most people that are going to go back and read it for the first time will probably realize that it's it's kind of out of date um for example like there's a really heavy emphasis in the agile manifesto on co-location and face-to-face collaboration over tools and processes and you can tell it was like clearly written before slack zoom and like webex were like big things because it was like clearly written before Slack, Zoom, and like WebEx were like big things because it was like,
而且只有四个核心点，然后我认为宣言本身有 12 个点。但这是一本很好的读物，可以围绕敏捷背后的意图建立视角。当这些人聚在一起并发展这种思维方式时，它旨在解决什么问题。而且我认为，你知道，大多数第一次回去阅读它的人可能会意识到，它有点过时了。例如，敏捷宣言中非常强调同地办公和面对面协作，而不是工具和流程。你可以看出它显然是在 Slack、Zoom 和 WebEx 成为大热门之前写的，因为它显然是在 Slack、Zoom 和 WebEx 成为大热门之前写的，因为它就像是，
no, we gotta get people in the same room. And like, that's how they collaborate. It's like, well, reality of the situation today is that that's not necessarily the case. But it's a really good read, I think, to get behind the driving forces of Agile, behind the intentions, and really understand the tenants.
不，我们必须把人们聚在同一个房间里。而且，你知道，这就是他们协作的方式。就像是，好吧，今天的情况是，情况不一定如此。但它是一本很好的读物，我认为可以深入了解敏捷的驱动力，背后的意图，并真正理解这些原则。
Another resource that really kind of helped me in the early days is a book called The Agile Samurai. And I think it's kind of a quintessential read when it comes to understanding agile. And I like it because it does a lot of compare and contrast between agile and waterfall ways of working too. And so it compares what we're aiming at and trying to get to with Agile and kind of what used to be with waterfall ways of working. And if you're coming from that waterfall way of working, or that's what you're used to, or that's what you're being taught in school, or that's kind of what you know and imagine
另一个在早期真正帮助我的资源是一本名为《敏捷武士》（The Agile Samurai）的书。我认为在理解敏捷方面，它是一本典型的读物。我喜欢它，因为它也做了很多敏捷和瀑布式工作方式的比较和对比。所以它比较了我们用敏捷瞄准和试图达到的目标，以及过去瀑布式工作方式的情况。如果你来自那种瀑布式工作方式，或者那是你习惯的，或者那是你在学校被教导的，或者那是你所知道和想象的
project management to be, it helps paint that picture. It's a little bit contrary to that. I also really love it too, because to your point, it doesn't assume as a reader that you know anything. It explains like every single concept in the book from, you know, CICD to agile to the different ways of working, it gives really good analogies. And it's not that assumptive kind of read of like, all right, you know, 50% of this, we're going to teach you the next 50%. It's like, you know, you know, nothing about it. How do we get you off the ground and start comparing this to things and making analogies that are really easy to grasp versus all of this assumed knowledge that we think you might have?
项目管理的样子，它有助于描绘那幅图景。它与此有点相反。我也真的很喜欢它，因为正如你所说，它不假设读者知道任何东西。它解释了书中的每一个概念，从 CICD 到敏捷，再到不同的工作方式，它给出了非常好的类比。它不是那种假设性的读物，比如，“好吧，你知道这 50%，我们要教你剩下的 50%。” 而是，你知道，你对它一无所知。我们如何让你起步，并开始将此与事物进行比较，并做出非常容易理解的类比，而不是所有这些我们认为你可能拥有的假设知识？
And then the third resource that I can't recommend this one enough, it's a book called The Phoenix Project. Maybe you guys have heard of it or maybe you've read it. No, it sounds awesome. Okay. Take a note. Basically, it presents like a picture of an organization that's working in a very waterfall-centric way that is in major disarray after one of their projects that they were supposed to launch to transform the business and bring them into the new modern era basically fails and goes way over budget, way over time, and basically flops. And it's all about – it's this hypothetical kind of picture they paint as a company. The company is called Parts Unlimited, and so it's not like, you know, any specific company they're targeting out of. It's all fictional. But it's all about how these different characters in the book kind of adapt their ways of working
然后第三个资源，我怎么推荐都不为过，是一本名为《凤凰项目》（The Phoenix Project）的书。也许你们听说过，或者也许你们读过。不，听起来很棒。好的。记下来。基本上，它呈现了一个以非常瀑布式方式工作的组织，在他们本应启动以转型业务并带他们进入新现代时代的项目之一失败、严重超支、严重超时并基本上彻底失败后，陷入了巨大的混乱。这完全是——这是他们描绘的一家公司的假设性图景。这家公司叫 Parts Unlimited，所以它不像，你知道，他们针对的任何特定公司。这完全是虚构的。但这完全是关于书中的不同角色如何调整他们的工作方式
and go through this agile and DevOps transformation, ultimately, and come up the other side as a completely different organization. And the cool thing about this book, too, is that there's characters in it, there's character development, and people have different roles. And it keeps on coming back to the same people as opposed to, you know, just being this high level academic kind of read. It's actually a little bit more fun, because it puts it into practice. And it's funny, too, because I think you can see a lot of similarities between like some of the characters in the book, and probably some of the people that you'll end up working with, just in terms of their personalities, and, and all the things like that. So those are those are
并经历这种敏捷和 DevOps 转型，最终，并作为一家完全不同的组织从另一端走出来。这本书也很酷的一点是，里面有角色，有角色发展，人们有不同的角色。它不断回到同样的人身上，而不是，你知道，仅仅是这种高水平的学术读物。它实际上更有趣，因为它付诸实践。而且它也很有趣，因为我认为你可以看到书中的一些角色和可能最终与你一起工作的一些人之间的许多相似之处，就他们的个性而言，以及所有这些事情。所以这些是
the resources that I really love., again, to your point, they don't have this like assumptive, they don't have this, they're not assumptive in saying like, oh, you already know about Agile or you develop software in a multinational organization and you're used to working this way, so you should know this. We're going to teach you something else. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So I think, does it make sense to sort of pull out one component, like maybe just
我真的很喜欢的资源。同样，正如你所说，它们没有这种假设性，它们不是假设性的，说“哦，你已经了解敏捷，或者你在跨国组织中开发软件，并且你习惯于这样工作，所以你应该知道这一点。我们要教你别的东西。” 是的，这完全说得通。所以我想，抽出一个组件，比如可能只是
the two week sprint methodology and just say, you know, try this first. Like, so if someone comes to you, um, and, and they want to adopt agile, is there sort of, is it incremental like that? Or, or is it really just a deconstruction of what they're doing now? I think it should be. I mean, we get this question all the time. And because I'm involved on our go-to-market team, you know, I spend most of my day working with our customers that are using our product. And by far, the number one question that we get is, you know, how do we get started with Agile or what framework do we adopt? We're starting from a place
两周冲刺方法论，然后说，你知道，先试试这个，这有意义吗？所以如果有人来找你，嗯，他们想采用敏捷，是否有某种，它是像那样渐进的吗？还是它真的只是对他们现在所做事情的解构？我认为应该是。我的意思是，我们一直被问到这个问题。而且因为我参与了我们的市场进入团队，你知道，我大部分时间都在与使用我们产品的客户一起工作。到目前为止，我们得到的第一个问题是，你知道，我们如何开始敏捷，或者我们采用什么框架？我们从一个
where we're not very Agile today. We kind of organize work a little bit. Tell me, you must have all the answers. You see a bunch of different teams. Is it Scrum? Is it Kanban? Give me the real deal here. What do I just need to adopt so that I can stay on Agile
我们今天不太敏捷的地方开始。我们稍微组织了一下工作。告诉我，你一定有所有的答案。你看到了很多不同的团队。是 Scrum 吗？是看板吗？给我真正的答案。我只需要采用什么，这样我才能保持敏捷
and kind of get to the point of Agile working? So we encounter this all the time. And I think there's a few big things when you step back that I always recommend to teams when they're thinking about how to get started with agile. And the first thing is to think about what success looks like for you and your team, kind of where you're at today. And what does that picture of like success look like in terms of where you'd like to be six months from now, a year from now, 18 months from now? Don't think about tools and processes just yet. Define success because that ultimately allows, I think, the organization to take a progressive approach that balances speed, visibility, predictability, and really change management within the organization.
并达到敏捷工作的程度？所以我们一直遇到这种情况。我认为当你退后一步时，有几件大事，我总是建议团队在考虑如何开始敏捷时参考。第一件事是思考对你和你的团队来说成功是什么样子的，你今天处于什么位置。以及那种成功在六个月后、一年后、18 个月后你想达到的位置是什么样子的？先不要考虑工具和流程。定义成功，因为我认为这最终允许组织采取一种平衡速度、可见性、可预测性和组织内变革管理的渐进式方法。
And so thinking about success, I feel like, is a really good first step in terms of thinking about what flavor of agile you want to ultimately adopt. I'm also a really big fan of teams easing into a new process and building those good habits along the way, as opposed to going through this culture shock of suddenly adopting a new way of working and not knowing how to do it. And when teams are adopting agile, you know, methodologies, whether it's Scrum or Kanban or anything in between, I don't think it should be an all or nothing approach. You know, that suddenly you're working in this new way of working. You mentioned like Scrum, for example. So if you want to deconstruct that one and focus on that, you know, just to connect that to the, what I just kind of mentioned,
所以思考成功，我觉得是思考你最终想要采用哪种敏捷风格的一个很好的第一步。我也非常喜欢团队慢慢适应新流程并在此过程中养成好习惯，而不是经历这种突然采用新工作方式却不知道如何做的文化冲击。当团队采用敏捷方法论时，无论是 Scrum 还是看板，还是介于两者之间的任何东西，我认为这不应该是一种全有或全无的方法。你知道，突然之间你就在以这种新的方式工作。你提到了 Scrum，例如。所以如果你想解构那个并专注于那个，你知道，只是为了把它连接到我刚才提到的，
like we've seen teams who are like, well, we ultimately want to end up working in a very Scrum style way. We think that's kind of core to our success, but you know, maybe they start with certain elements of that framework. So they still, for example, organize work into two week sprints, but they're not yet at the point where they're able to estimate or where they're able to understand their velocity. And that's okay. Software estimation is like one of the hardest things I think to do when you're building software and knowing how long things are going to take and how complex things they are. And probably if you started estimating from day one, that would
就像我们看到那些团队，他们说，“好吧，我们最终想以一种非常 Scrum 的风格工作。我们认为这对我们的成功至关重要。” 但你知道，也许他们从那个框架的某些元素开始。所以他们仍然，例如，将工作组织成两周的冲刺，但他们还没有达到能够估算或能够理解他们的速度（velocity）的程度。这没关系。软件估算是我认为在构建软件时最难做的事情之一，知道事情需要多长时间以及它们有多复杂。如果你从第一天就开始估算，那可能
actually slow your team down and create more friction in adopting that new process. And so that's where, you know, I really, I think an iterative approach is important, where you're like, we're gonna, you know, adopt certain parts of this, of this methodology, not all the parts, because they may not make sense, kind of given where we're at today. And this is where we want to get to over time. But you know, this is kind of where we're going to start. So yeah, that sense yeah i think um yeah to your point i mean if you haven't broken things down into two-week chunks there's no way you're going to predict what you can do in two weeks exactly it's impossible right and so and so um yeah the first step i think is yeah getting that methodology and and um maybe even similar to like a shadow, shadow database type thing. You know,
实际上会减慢你的团队速度，并在采用该新流程时产生更多的摩擦。所以这就是为什么，你知道，我真的，我认为迭代方法很重要，你就像，“我们将，你知道，采用这种方法论的某些部分，而不是所有部分，因为考虑到我们今天所处的位置，它们可能没有意义。这是我们随着时间推移想要达到的目标。但你知道，这是我们要开始的地方。” 所以是的，那种感觉，是的，我想，嗯，是的，正如你所说，如果你没有把事情分解成两周的块，你就不可能预测你在两周内能做什么，完全不可能，对吧？所以，嗯，是的，第一步，我想是，是的，获得那种方法论，并且，嗯，也许甚至类似于影子数据库之类的东西。你知道，
if your project manager really needs to stay on top of things, you can have this sort of transition period where, you know, it's a little painful, but you do things in, in your current project management flow and you do things in, let's say Zen hub just maybe for a quarter to sort of, you know, you know, make that shift. Exactly, yeah. I think maybe organizations can be a little heavy-handed at times
如果你的项目经理真的需要掌握情况，你可以有这种过渡期，你知道，这有点痛苦，但你在你当前的项目管理流程中做事情，你在，比如说 Zen hub 中做事情，也许只是为了一个季度，以某种方式，你知道，你知道，做出那种转变。没错，是的。我认为也许组织有时会有点强硬
in enforcing agile ways of working. Typically, when we see that, it's a big predictor of organizations not being as successful with agile when people are really, really heavy-handed on the ways of working. But for most people that are adopting agile, there's no agile police force out there that if you're not using all the different parts of a methodology, they're going to come by and arrest you at your desk kind of thing. It's like, ease into it. No one's enforcing this kind of stuff. Do what works for the team, figure it out yourself, and eventually you'll get to the
在强制执行敏捷工作方式方面。通常，当我们看到这种情况时，这是组织在敏捷方面不太成功的一个重要预测指标，当人们在工作方式上非常、非常强硬时。但对于大多数采用敏捷的人来说，外面没有敏捷警察部队，如果你没有使用方法论的所有不同部分，他们就会过来在你的办公桌前逮捕你。就像是，慢慢适应它。没有人强制执行这种东西。做对团队有效的事情，自己弄清楚，最终你会达到
state that you want to be at. But upfront you know, upfront, there's, there's no point in investing in every single part of it. If you know that, like you said, uh, we've never organized work into two weeks before. So how are we possibly going to know how long, how much we can do in that timeframe? Right. Yeah. Yeah. Totally makes sense. So, um, so Zen hub is, um, in terms of Zen Hub itself as a product, if folks want to use it, is there a thing for students or is it free for open source projects or how can somebody try it out? Yeah. So if you're working on a commercial project today,
你想要达到的状态。但预先，你知道，预先，没有必要投资于它的每一个部分。如果你知道，就像你说的，嗯，我们以前从未把工作组织成两周。所以我们怎么可能知道在那个时间框架内我们能做多少？对吧。是的。是的。完全说得通。所以，嗯，所以 Zen hub 是，嗯，就 Zen Hub 本身作为一个产品而言，如果人们想使用它，是否有针对学生的版本，或者它对开源项目免费吗，或者某人如何尝试它？是的。所以如果你今天正在做一个商业项目，
it's a paid license for Zen Hub. And because of our proximity with GitHub and how closely we are integrated, we've tried really closely to follow their pricing model for it. So licensing on a per seat basis with just options for teams to go monthly or annual,
它是 Zen Hub 的付费许可证。而且因为我们与 GitHub 的亲近程度以及我们集成的紧密程度，我们非常努力地尝试遵循他们的定价模型。所以按席位许可，团队可以选择按月或按年付费，
depending on what their kind of use case is and where they're trying to get to. For students and open source teams though, those are communities that I think are really important to us and really near and dear. So we actually offer the product for free for students if you're in an academic program and open source teams that are working on open source initiatives or open source software.
取决于他们的用例是什么以及他们试图达到什么目标。不过，对于学生和开源团队，这些是我认为对我们非常重要且非常亲近的社区。所以我们实际上为学生（如果你在学术项目中）和正在从事开源倡议或开源软件的开源团队免费提供该产品。
I mean, I was a student once, we all were, and on the bottom of your list is paying money to purchase tools for software development of all the things that you could spend your money on in college or in high school. So we find most students don't really have the ability to pay anyways. But what I think has been really interesting actually is if you can get more students on your platform and get more people using your product, they take those tools with them into organization. That's right. platform and get more people using your product, they take those tools with them into organization.
我的意思是，我曾经也是学生，我们都是，而且在你的清单底部是支付金钱购买软件开发工具，在大学或高中里你可以把钱花在所有事情上。所以我们发现大多数学生无论如何都没有支付能力。但我认为实际上非常有趣的是，如果你能让更多的学生使用你的平台，让更多的人使用你的产品，他们会把这些工具带入组织。没错。平台，让更多的人使用你的产品，他们会把这些工具带入组织。
We end up recouping that cost when a student that was using our product in high school or using it in college ends up bringing it to an organization. We actually have this with a major customer that's a consumer bank up in Canada. They're using Zenhub because one of their interns over the summer actually was like, using this for a mechanical engineering course that I'm working on, you know, we're building a formula car basically for this project. And I want to be able to use it here too. And they were like, well, let's try it out kind of thing. And it's actually resulted in a pretty big customer, pretty nice logo for us. So it's pretty cool. Just the synergies that can come from that. But yeah, we're completely free for students and open source teams. So for those of you who are listening and want to try it out on your project, best way to get started is just to go to zenhub.com, sign up, download the extension or
当学生在高中或大学使用我们的产品，并最终将其带入某个组织时，我们最终会收回这部分成本。我们确实有一位主要客户就是加拿大的消费银行。他们使用 Zenhub 是因为他们的一位暑期实习生当时说：“我正在做的机械工程课程就在用这个，你知道，我们基本上是在为这个项目制造一辆方程式赛车。我也想在这里使用它。”他们当时就说：“好吧，那我们试试看。”这最终为我们带来了一个相当大的客户，一个非常不错的品牌。所以这真的很酷。这就是由此产生的协同效应。但没错，我们对学生和开源团队是完全免费的。所以对于正在收听并想在项目中尝试的你们，最好的入门方式就是访问 zenhub.com，注册，下载扩展程序或
access the web app. And then once you actually authorize Zenhub, you're going to be able to see that board overlay and the reports over top of your existing GitHub repos. So super easy, super frictionless to get started with as well. That sounds awesome. So this is a bit of a meta question, but I don't know why I just got curious about it. So for students, you probably are looking for like a.edu email address when they register, correct? Yeah. So that's typically how we ask students to reach out. Or we might ask for some information just about, you know, their project or what they're working on just to kind of make sure that there is like a use case behind it.
访问网页应用。一旦你授权了 Zenhub，你就能在现有的 GitHub 仓库之上看到看板覆盖层和报告。所以上手非常容易，没有任何阻碍。听起来太棒了。这是一个元问题，但我不知道为什么我突然对它感到好奇。那么对于学生，你们在他们注册时可能会寻找 .edu 邮箱地址，对吧？是的。这通常是我们要求学生联系我们的方式。或者我们可能会要求提供一些关于他们的项目或他们正在从事的工作的信息，以确保其背后确实有使用场景。
I mean, if you're a commercial project out there trying to game the tool space by signing up with an EDU email, you've gone to a lot of effort to do that, you know. Yeah, no. We're not trying to actively police that. I think we're just trying to make it as easy for students as possible. So, yeah, we look for a.edu email or, you know, if students are coming in from a personal email, because that's what's connected to their GitHub account. Sometimes, you know, we just ask them like the name of the course and if they can shoot that back to us in an email, I mean, that's more than enough. It's a very low burden of proof, I think. And how do you and GitHub handle the per seat? Like, is that also kind of, you know, on the honor system in a sense that you're, you know,
我的意思是，如果你是一个商业项目，试图通过用 EDU 邮箱注册来钻工具空间的空子，那你为了做到这一点已经付出了很大的努力。是的，不。我们并没有试图主动监管这一点。我认为我们只是想让学生尽可能轻松地使用。所以，是的，我们会寻找 .edu 邮箱，或者，如果学生使用个人邮箱，因为那是他们 GitHub 账号关联的邮箱。有时，我们只是询问课程名称，如果他们能通过电子邮件回复我们，那这就足够了。我认为这是一种负担很低的证明方式。那么你和 GitHub 是如何处理按席位收费的呢？这是否也算是一种荣誉制度，即你……
because it's, I would imagine, like, I don't really know how you would build a website that has a per seat charge, right? Yeah. So it kind of maps back both for GitHub and for ZenHub to the actual license. And in our kind of licensing governance, I think that we've built into our product, and I'm sure GitHub has done the actual license. And in our kind of licensing governance, I think that we've built into our product, and I'm sure GitHub has done the same too, there is that concept of this organization
因为我想象不出你会如何构建一个按席位收费的网站，对吧？是的。所以对于 GitHub 和 ZenHub 来说，它都映射回实际的许可证。在我们构建到产品中的许可治理中，我相信 GitHub 也做了同样的事情，即存在这样一个概念：这个组织
has paid for 10 licenses. So when that 11th person from that organization tries to come in, they're going to be kind of directed to go and ask their team for another license on top of that. So the seats are, there's one-to-one mapping between seats and GitHub accounts. Exactly, yeah. Oh, yeah, that makes so much sense.
已经支付了 10 个许可证。所以当该组织的第 11 个人尝试进入时，他们会被引导去向他们的团队申请额外的许可证。所以席位是……席位和 GitHub 账号之间是一对一的映射。完全正确，是的。哦，是的，这非常有道理。
Two users can't use the same seat at any given time. Like I said, when that 11th person comes in, then we ask them to go and request a license from their administrator. And usually, you know, there's a valid use case for that person or that individual kind of joining the rest of the team. And so more often than not, it just kind of goes through. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, the reason why I ask is just kind of random.
两个用户不能在同一时间使用同一个席位。就像我说的，当第 11 个人进来时，我们会要求他们去向管理员申请许可证。通常，那个人或个人加入团队的其他成员确实有合理的用例。所以大多数情况下，它就直接通过了。是的，这很有道理。是的，我问的原因只是随口一问。
I was talking to somebody the other day about how they used to have, I used to do, I have a minor in digital media. So we used to use this program called 3D Studio Max that was, I don't know, thousands of dollars at the time. Now it's probably an open source version, but they actually had a hardware dongle that you had to plug in. I don't know if it was USB, I don't quite remember, but it might've even been PS2 port, but you have to plug in this hardware dongle, otherwise the software wouldn't start. And it just, I don't actually know uh i think nowadays it's all basically tied to your identity and so so most sites you know most most most companies are not going to tell three employees to use the same identity just to save uh yeah so that works out well it's it's kind of crazy just on that point too to think about like what software used to be like before subscription services and sas was really a
前几天我和某人聊天，谈到他们过去常做的事情，我辅修过数字媒体。所以我们过去常使用一个叫 3D Studio Max 的程序，当时要花费数千美元。现在可能有了开源版本，但他们当时有一个必须插入的硬件加密狗。我不知道是不是 USB，我记不太清了，甚至可能是 PS2 接口，但你必须插入这个硬件加密狗，否则软件就无法启动。我其实不知道……我想现在这一切基本上都与你的身份绑定了，所以大多数网站，你知道，大多数公司不会告诉三名员工使用同一个身份来节省……是的，所以这运作得很好。想到订阅服务和 SaaS 真正成为……之前软件的样子，这真是太疯狂了。
big thing yeah and i mean i even remember like uh uh you know i probably should publicly say but like downloading like uh pirated copies of like the adobe software in university oh yeah i'm not gonna buy like okay we'll find them cat's out of the bag on this one um well now they have a good model for students where you can pay. I think maybe I kind of stole it under here, but you can pay something like $10 a month. Exactly, yeah. For free or something. You know, and it's like I can't imagine a world where we'd actually bundle our software up, put it in a box, send it to a customer, charge them $1,000 a license of thing and then and that's that um it's just crazy to think about like the delivery involved in that is so complicated and like getting your product
大趋势。是的，我的意思是，我甚至记得，你知道，我可能不应该公开说，但就像在大学里下载像 Adobe 软件的盗版副本。哦，是的，我不会买……好吧，我们会找到他们的，这件事已经泄露了。嗯，现在他们为学生提供了一个很好的模式，你可以付费。我想我可能在这里偷用过，但你可以每月支付 10 美元左右。完全正确，是的。免费或类似的东西。你知道，我无法想象一个我们会把软件打包、装进盒子里、寄给客户、每个许可证收费 1,000 美元的世界，然后……这太疯狂了，想到其中涉及的交付过程是如此复杂，而且把你的产品
into your hands of your customers and stuff like that it's just like it's a completely different way of thinking but yeah that makes sense how do you um um so there's a there's a per seat license but then if if if someone's at a bigger company and they want you know your help or they want they want someone's help from zen Hub, how does that work? Is that handled on sort of more of a case-by-case basis? Yeah, so we actually offer through our pricing page a couple different ways to actually, I guess a couple different tiers. So one is our growth plan, and that's a little bit more self-service. It tends to be used by kind of smaller teams that come in and say, hey, we think this tool is going to be a great fit for our workflow and we want to leverage this and use it, but
送到客户手中等等，这完全是另一种思维方式。但是的，这很有道理。你是怎么……所以有一个按席位收费的许可证，但如果有人在一家大公司，他们想要你的帮助，或者他们想要 ZenHub 某人的帮助，那是怎么运作的？那是按个案处理的吗？是的，我们实际上通过我们的定价页面提供了几种不同的方式，我想是几种不同的层级。一种是我们的成长计划，那稍微自助服务一点。它往往被一些较小的团队使用，他们进来并说，嘿，我们认为这个工具非常适合我们的工作流程，我们想利用并使用它，但是
we maybe don't need a lot of help. We're fairly comfortable with that concept. We may have support questions from time to time or we're a small team. We can figure things out for ourselves. Then we actually have an enterprise tier and that involves a lot more of the priority support, having a customer success person that's dedicated to working with your team. And then we get to do a lot of just the mechanics around like actually purchasing and procuring too, where it's, you know, we can do invoice billing
我们可能不需要太多帮助。我们对这个概念相当熟悉。我们可能偶尔会有支持问题，或者我们是一个小团队。我们可以自己解决问题。然后我们实际上有一个企业层级，这涉及更多的优先支持，拥有一个专门与你的团队合作的客户成功专员。然后我们还可以处理很多关于实际购买和采购的机制，比如，我们可以进行发票结算
and stuff like that. That's kind of less interesting. But the success piece is really, I think that core differentiator there. And we find that a lot of larger teams really opt into that because they want to be able to have someone answer those questions for them and help apply the tool to their ways of working or help suggest new ways of working. And that all comes back to those conversations we had about working with teams to help them kind of adopt
等等。这部分不太有趣。但我认为成功部分确实是核心差异化因素。我们发现许多大型团队确实选择了这一点，因为他们希望能够有人为他们回答这些问题，并帮助将该工具应用到他们的工作方式中，或者帮助建议新的工作方式。这一切都回到了我们之前关于与团队合作以帮助他们采用
Agile and iterate on their approach to Agile and give them those suggestions on how to best do that, check in with them frequently to make sure that things are working. A lot of, like I said, larger teams really value that. Even though they have support for that within their organization anyways, they may have dedicated resources to that. I think it helps to have someone who is a lot more connected to maybe the tool that they're using as well because they can say, okay, well, our mandate is this, how do we kind of fit that mandate into the tool? And, you know, maybe we say that you can't, sometimes we need to go back and see if we can not change that
敏捷并迭代他们的敏捷方法，并为他们提供如何最好地做到这一点的建议，经常与他们核对以确保事情进展顺利。正如我所说，很多大型团队非常重视这一点。即使他们在组织内部已经有了相应的支持，他们可能有专门的资源来处理这个问题。我认为有一个与他们正在使用的工具联系更紧密的人会有所帮助，因为他们可以说，好吧，我们的任务是这个，我们如何将该任务融入到工具中？而且，你知道，也许我们说你不能，有时我们需要回去看看我们是否可以不改变那个
mandate, but adapt that, or here's how you can do it and give customers that lens. Yeah, that makes sense. So what about, is it, is, is ZenHub integrated, like, let's say, Outlook? What are sort of really useful? I mean, I imagine it's integrated with Slack. So at the end of a sprint, maybe there's a Slack post. Yeah, we did. That was the second integration that we actually built was into Slack. And obviously, because so many teams are working through there and so much work and conversation
任务，而是调整它，或者这是你可以做到的方式，并给客户提供那种视角。是的，这很有道理。那么，ZenHub 是否集成了，比如，Outlook？什么是非常有用的？我的意思是，我想它与 Slack 集成了。所以在冲刺结束时，也许会有一个 Slack 帖子。是的，我们做了。那是我们实际上构建的第二个集成，就是集成到 Slack 中。显然，因为这么多团队在那里工作，而且这么多工作和对话
and even collaboration passes through Slack at some point in the project, that was a really important integration for us to try to build that point where we could take some of the data from Zenhub and kind of present it in that view. I think that also speaks a little bit back to that persona as well. And we talked about this a little bit earlier on, but the personas that are spending most time in Slack are probably their project managers, your product owners, the people that are having active conversations around that. Some of the things that we do, for example, are showing teams when things have changed
甚至协作在项目的某个时刻都会通过 Slack 进行，这对我们来说是一个非常重要的集成，试图建立那个点，我们可以从 Zenhub 获取一些数据并以那种视图呈现出来。我认为这也稍微回到了那个角色。我们之前稍微谈过这一点，但在 Slack 中花费最多时间的角色可能是他们的项目经理、产品负责人，那些围绕它进行积极对话的人。例如，我们做的一些事情是向团队展示事情何时发生了变化
on their board or when pipeline transitions have happened for certain issues on their board so they don't necessarily need to see all of that inside the product. Transitions have happened, pipeline transitions have happened for certain issues on their board. So they don't necessarily need to see all of that inside the product. They can actually use Slack to keep apprised on those different updates that are actually happening. Yeah, that totally makes sense. So you mentioned pipelines. Can you go over just a real quick kind of glossary of various terms? So I think we mentioned sprints, I think, just to recap, sprints are basically these two week chunks where you set something in advance. So at the end of two weeks, we want the customer
在他们的看板上，或者当看板上的某些议题发生了流水线转换时，所以他们不一定需要在产品内部看到所有这些。转换已经发生，某些议题的流水线转换已经在他们的看板上发生。所以他们不一定需要在产品内部看到所有这些。他们实际上可以使用 Slack 来随时了解正在发生的那些不同更新。是的，这完全有道理。所以你提到了流水线。你能简单过一遍各种术语的词汇表吗？所以我想我们提到了冲刺，我想，只是回顾一下，冲刺基本上是这两周的时间块，你提前设定了一些东西。所以在两周结束时，我们希望客户
experience to look like this. And then you see you can measure that and pace yourself. And then sprints are part of Scrum, if I remember correctly? Yes, sprints are kind of a very Scrum-centric term. Got it. And so what are pipelines then? Yeah, it's a good question. So pipelines, at least the way that we talk about them, there's a very familiar concept in a lot of agile methodologies and a lot of agile ways of working that kind of anchors around the different phases, I guess you could say, or the different kind of swim lanes within your software development process. And so ideally,
体验看起来像这样。然后你可以衡量它并调整自己的节奏。然后冲刺是 Scrum 的一部分，如果我没记错的话？是的，冲刺是一种非常以 Scrum 为中心的术语。明白了。那么什么是流水线呢？是的，这是一个好问题。所以流水线，至少是我们谈论它们的方式，在许多敏捷方法论和许多敏捷工作方式中有一个非常熟悉的概念，它围绕着不同的阶段，或者你可以说是你软件开发过程中的不同泳道。所以理想情况下，
you have a pipeline for each different stage that a work item would have to go through before it's actually delivered to the customer. So one of those could be a backlog. One of those could be a pipeline that says in progress. One of those could be a pipeline that says in progress. One of those could be a pipeline that says testing. One of those could be a pipeline that says QA, ready for deployment, and then maybe like closed or completed work. And so essentially what the pipelines help do is they help to actually ascribe a physical state to where that issue or where that work item actually lives within your overall workflow. And so you're able to see and kind of trace work through the different stages
你为工作项在实际交付给客户之前必须经过的每个不同阶段都有一个流水线。其中之一可能是积压工作。其中之一可能是一个显示“进行中”的流水线。其中之一可能是一个显示“进行中”的流水线。其中之一可能是一个显示“测试中”的流水线。其中之一可能是一个显示“质量保证”、“准备部署”，然后可能是“已关闭”或“已完成”工作的流水线。所以流水线基本上有助于为该议题或该工作项在你的整体工作流程中实际所处的位置赋予一个物理状态。所以你能够看到并追踪工作经过
of your software development process or the different stages that, you know, work needs to go through before it's actually delivered. Now, if you're thinking about Agile for the first time and you're really just, you know, going to be using it on a personal project or maybe an open source project or a school project, you know, the classic columns are kind of like to do, doing, done, right? With a backlog of like, well, this is all the stuff I have to do. I want to prioritize it. Here's all the stuff I'm currently doing that's in progress. Here's all the stuff I've done. So at least I can look back and we can measure what we've done over the past, you know, however long we want to measure that for, what my current focus is on, and do I have way too many things in that or not enough things in that? And then this is eventually the to-do list of all the items that I have to check off.
你的软件开发过程的不同阶段，或者工作在实际交付之前需要经过的不同阶段。现在，如果你是第一次考虑敏捷，并且你真的只是打算在一个个人项目、或者开源项目、或者学校项目中使用它，经典的列就像是“待办”、“进行中”、“已完成”，对吧？有一个积压工作，比如，好吧，这些是我必须做的所有事情。我想优先处理它们。这是我目前正在做的所有事情，即“进行中”。这是我已完成的所有事情。所以至少我可以回顾过去，我们可以衡量我们在过去，你知道，无论我们想衡量多久的时间里完成了什么，我目前的重点是什么，我在那里面放了太多的东西还是不够？然后这最终是我必须勾选的所有项目的待办事项列表。
And so it's that very, like, systems way of kind of thinking. where the software development life cycle is much more complex. And you see boards with maybe 10, 15 pipelines on them of all the different stages that work actually needs to go through before it can be delivered or put in a system where it can be delivered to the customer. So that's what we refer to as pipelines as it applies to kind of, I guess, a task board or kind of a workspace. And that's something that's pretty popular, not just in Zen Hub, and it's not really something we, a paradigm we invented, but
所以这是一种非常系统化的思维方式。软件开发生命周期要复杂得多。你会看到看板上可能有 10 到 15 个流水线，涵盖了工作在交付或放入可以交付给客户的系统之前必须经过的所有不同阶段。所以这就是我们所说的流水线，因为它适用于任务看板或工作区。这在 ZenHub 中非常流行，这并不是我们发明的范式，但
you'll see it in all the other project management tools or all the other agile planning tools out there as well, whether it's Trello or Jira or any of the other ones you're familiar with. That makes sense. And so the pipeline kind of handles your sort of dependencies. So if something has to go through two weeks of QA and it's, it's due in 10 days, you have, you have a big, and you haven't finished coding, you have a big problem and you already know it. You don't have to wait nine days and then say, Oh, we have a problem because you've, so you know, that that pipeline, there's, there's some fixed costs there. And there's some variable costs in terms of time in
你也会在所有其他项目管理工具或所有其他敏捷规划工具中看到它，无论是 Trello、Jira 还是你熟悉的任何其他工具。这很有道理。所以流水线处理了你的依赖关系。如果某件事必须经过两周的质量保证，而且它在 10 天后到期，你有一个大问题，而且你还没有完成编码，你已经知道有一个大问题了。你不必等到九天后才说，哦，我们有一个问题，因为你已经……所以你知道，那个流水线，那里有一些固定成本。而且在时间方面有一些可变成本
that. Yeah. And I think about it from a visibility perspective too, in terms of, you know, number one thing that organizing work in that way gives you is the two important concepts both start with a P. So they're easy to remember. It's priority and progress, right? So is this the most important thing that I can work on? Is it prioritized at the top of our column? Is it kind of down below and in terms of things that we really, you know, aren't super priority for us? And the other one is progress. So where is it at any given point in my workflow? And understanding those two things even, it gives a fundamentally different lens to a project than like, here's a list of things that I have, and maybe some of them are being worked on,
。是的。而且我也从可见性的角度来考虑它，你知道，以这种方式组织工作给你的第一件事是两个重要的概念都以 P 开头。所以它们很容易记住。它是优先级（Priority）和进度（Progress），对吧？所以这是我能做的最重要的事情吗？它在我们的列顶部被优先处理了吗？它是在下面，属于那些我们真的，你知道，对我们来说不是超级优先的事情吗？另一个是进度。所以它在我的工作流程中的任何给定点处于什么位置？了解这两件事，即使是这样，也给项目提供了一个与“这是一堆我有的事情，也许其中一些正在进行中”完全不同的视角，
maybe some of them aren't being worked on. I don't necessarily know what are these things are most important, what we need to do first to your point, like what are the dependencies in this? So that's where we're boards can really kind of help with the organization information. Yeah, totally makes sense. So, so what about actually, so how many engineers work at Zen Hub? Yeah, we have a team is 34. We have 14 engineers. Got it. And so what is a typical day for an engineer? So actually, is Zed Hub distributed or is it mostly in Vancouver? Yeah, that's a good question. So our product and engineering teams are mostly up in Vancouver. Our go-to-market team tends to be a little bit more located where our customers are. So we have people in the Bay Area. We have
也许其中一些没有在进行中。我不一定知道这些事情中哪些是最重要的，我们首先需要做什么，就像你说的，这里的依赖关系是什么？所以这就是看板在组织信息方面真正能提供帮助的地方。是的，完全有道理。那么，实际上，有多少工程师在 ZenHub 工作？是的，我们的团队有 34 人。我们有 14 名工程师。明白了。那么工程师的典型一天是什么样的？所以实际上，ZenHub 是分布式的，还是主要在温哥华？是的，这是一个好问题。我们的产品和工程团队大多在温哥华。我们的市场进入团队往往更靠近我们的客户所在的地方。所以我们在湾区有人。我们有
a few folks in Seattle. And so a little bit more distributed to give us some coverage and to be a little bit closer to our customers. On the kind of remote aspect of things, though, you know, we started out as a very co-located team. And it was because everyone that was working on Zenhub at the time was based up in Vancouver. But, you know, we saw an opportunity to bring talent into the team as we grew the company and it wasn't necessarily just based here and to draw from some of the biggest talent markets in the world, like the Bay Area and like Seattle, because there's some fantastic, you know, talent there on the development side and fantastic talent on the go-to-market side there. And so that was
几个人在西雅图。所以分布稍微广一点，以便给我们一些覆盖范围，并更接近我们的客户。不过，在远程方面，你知道，我们最初是一个非常集中办公的团队。这是因为当时在 Zenhub 工作的所有人都在温哥华。但是，你知道，随着我们公司的发展，我们看到了将人才引入团队的机会，它不一定只是基于这里，并从世界上一些最大的人才市场中汲取人才，比如湾区和西雅图，因为那里在开发方面有一些非常棒的人才，在市场进入方面也有非常棒的人才。所以那是
kind of one of our initial kind of forays into thinking about building, I wouldn't say a truly distributed company, but having remote people working at the company. And then while our engineering and product teams are actually based in Vancouver, there also are now some engineers that are actually working remotely. And this isn't necessarily something that we sat down and planned out and said, you know, we're going to shift from being all in one office to being distributed over the next year, is more a matter of, I think, circumstance for some of these people that they could no longer work in Vancouver or could no longer be in Vancouver for personal or for family reasons or
我们最初尝试考虑建立的，我不会说是一个真正分布式的公司，但有远程人员在公司工作。然后，虽然我们的工程和产品团队实际上位于温哥华，但现在也有一些工程师实际上在远程工作。这不一定是我们坐下来计划好的，说，你知道，我们要在接下来的一年里从全员在一个办公室转变为分布式，这更多是出于这些人的情况，他们不能再在温哥华工作，或者由于个人或家庭原因不能再在温哥华，或者
whatever have that be. And it offered us kind of a good opportunity, though, to kind of test aspects of that remote culture with people that we really knew and that we trusted. So rather than like hiring someone, you know, and having them off in a province or a state that, you know, and having never met that person in person, you know, it was people that were in this office that kind of knew and understood the culture that then through, you know, circumstances had to be remote, that we kind of let go and do that. And so it gave us kind of this interesting way to kind of adapt in almost into a remote working culture. And honestly, it's been it's been really easy, I think, to adapt to. And most people I think you'd ask at Zenhub would say the same thing in terms of doesn't create any more friction, you know, these people are still reachable and
无论是什么原因。但这确实为我们提供了一个很好的机会，去测试那种远程文化的各个方面，与我们真正了解和信任的人一起。所以与其雇佣某人，你知道，让他们在某个省或州，你知道，而且从未亲自见过那个人，你知道，这是办公室里那些了解并理解文化的人，然后通过，你知道，情况不得不远程，我们放手让他们这样做。所以它给了我们一种有趣的方式来适应几乎是远程的工作文化。老实说，我认为适应起来非常容易。我想你在 Zenhub 问的大多数人都会说同样的话，即它不会造成任何额外的摩擦，你知道，这些人仍然可以联系到，
accessible and easy to work with. And most people are happy, obviously, because, you know, I think they get to, obviously, you know, be in a circumstance that's kind of comfortable for them. But there's also a lot of ways that we make ourselves accessible to those people as well, to make sure that you don't have that degraded experience or poor experience, because you happen to be working in a different time zone or happen to be working, you know, the world so yeah that makes sense probably a lot of communication um you know a lot of zoom a lot of slack exactly same players that you'd expect those those are our products that we use religiously um and then obviously a lot of collaboration too and inside of github issues and a lot of commenting back and forth on issues using zen hub to kind of
并且容易合作。而且大多数人显然很高兴，因为，你知道，我想他们能够，显然，你知道，处于一种对他们来说很舒适的环境中。但我们也有很多方式让自己对这些人保持可访问性，以确保你不会因为你恰好在不同的时区工作或恰好在工作，你知道，世界，所以是的，这很有道理，可能有很多沟通，嗯，你知道，很多 Zoom，很多 Slack，完全是你所期望的那些参与者，那些是我们虔诚使用的产品，然后显然还有很多协作，在 GitHub 议题内部，以及在议题上使用 ZenHub 来进行大量来回评论，以
synchronize that as well so um, you know, it's kind of a cool story of, yeah, we didn't really start with those intentions in mind. We slowly became remote, but it's been working really well for us. And it's given us a new way of thinking about things to the point where I think now we're feeling a lot more comfortable maybe making some hires and stepping outside of that comfort zone and saying, we actually are fine with having people in different geographies and different areas of the world. So long as you know, they're willing to spend some time in the office up front, at least to get a feel for the culture and for the people that work here. And yeah, yeah, makes sense. So kind of walk us through like a day in the life of a Zen Hub engineer.
同步这一点，所以，嗯，你知道，这是一个很酷的故事，是的，我们并没有真正带着这些意图开始。我们慢慢地变成了远程，但它对我们来说运作得非常好。它给了我们一种新的思考方式，以至于我认为现在我们感觉更舒服了，也许会进行一些招聘，走出那个舒适区，说，我们实际上不介意让人们在不同的地理位置和世界不同的地区工作。只要你知道，他们愿意在前期花一些时间在办公室，至少是为了感受一下文化和在这里工作的人。是的，是的，有道理。所以带我们了解一下 ZenHub 工程师的一天。
So what are they doing kind of day to day? For sure. I'm probably not the best person to comment on that because I'm not an engineer myself, but I see a lot of what our engineers are working on. And there's, I think, some interesting takeaways, at least that I can share there. So I would say that the first thing is that we've actually organized,
所以他们每天都在做什么？当然。我可能不是评论这个的最佳人选，因为我自己不是工程师。但我看到了很多我们的工程师正在做的事情。而且我认为有一些有趣的收获，至少我可以分享一下。所以我会说第一件事是我们实际上已经组织了，
and this is motivated from the Spotify way of working. You should probably add that to the resource list if people are interested in learning and understanding Agile. Spotify, actually, of all organizations, has done some fantastic writing on Agile and how you organize teams around Agile, particularly within organizations. Cool. We'll add that to the notes. Yeah.
而且这是受 Spotify 工作方式的启发。如果人们有兴趣学习和理解敏捷，你应该把那个加到资源列表中。Spotify，在所有组织中，实际上在敏捷以及你如何在组织内围绕敏捷组织团队方面写了一些非常棒的文章。酷。我们会把它加到笔记里。是的。
We adopted some of those core tenets from that way of working where we actually spun up what we call squads or engineering pods within our company. Even across all of those engineers, we don't have them all just working on the same thing at once and with the exact same focus at the same time. We actually have three different squads internally. Each one of them has a slightly separate focus. We have a back-end pod or squad. We have two front- end pods or squads,
我们采用了那种工作方式中的一些核心原则，我们实际上组建了我们称之为“小队（Squads）”或工程小组的东西。即使在所有这些工程师中，我们也没有让他们所有人同时在做同一件事，并且同时拥有完全相同的重点。我们内部实际上有三个不同的“小队”。每一个都有稍微不同的重点。我们有一个后端小组或小队。我们有两个前端小组或小队，
and they'll be working on, you know, different features or different parts of the product at any given time, depending on, you know, what's important to us and what we're kind of prioritizing. And within a certain kind of range or a certain kind of balance, we try to give these pods autonomy to work in the way that makes the most sense for them. So there's certain things that are kind of a must and that we fix. We don't want every team using a different communication tool. It all has to happen in Slack, for example. Nor do we want teams using different project management tools.
他们会根据，你知道，什么对我们很重要以及我们正在优先考虑什么，在任何给定时间处理不同的功能或产品的不同部分。在某种范围或某种平衡内，我们尽量给这些小组自主权，让他们以对他们最有意义的方式工作。所以有些事情是必须的，我们已经固定了。我们不希望每个团队使用不同的沟通工具。例如，这一切都必须在 Slack 中进行。我们也不希望团队使用不同的项目管理工具。
All of that is driven through GitHub and Zen Hub. So there's that kind of core set of tools and systems, but we give them autonomy in terms of working in a way that makes most sense and organizing in a way that makes most sense for them as a team. And most of us just from our history as a company have ended up working in a very scrum centric way. But for one of the last features that we actually built, one of the teams was actually testing out more of a Kanban centric way of working. And for those who are listening that don't necessarily know what that is, it's a little bit more of a continuous flow of work rather than organizing work into two-week sprints or increments.
这一切都是通过 GitHub 和 ZenHub 驱动的。所以有那种核心的工具和系统，但我们在他们以对他们团队最有意义的方式工作和组织方面给予他们自主权。我们大多数人只是从我们作为公司的历史来看，最终以一种非常以 Scrum 为中心的方式工作。但对于我们实际上构建的最后一个功能，其中一个团队实际上正在测试一种更以看板（Kanban）为中心的工作方式。对于那些正在收听且不一定知道那是什么的人来说，它更像是一种持续的工作流，而不是将工作组织成两周的冲刺或增量。
It's essentially just pulling from a backlog and saying, you know, I'm going to work on this and then this next and then this next kind of thing. And we're not going to have any of these be defined in terms of two-week sprints. We're just going to start picking them up as we have capacity and as we have time. Oh, interesting. Yeah. So it's a little bit more rapid pace of development. There's a lot less downtime between certain cycles and things like that. You also don't get as many strong KPIs, I think, in terms of like velocity and that predictability. But we tried that, I think, because we were trying to move very fast on something. That isn't to say you can't move fast with Scrum, but it's just a slightly different
它基本上只是从积压工作中提取，并说，你知道，我要做这个，然后是这个，然后是这个。我们不会让这些以两周冲刺的形式定义。我们只是要在我们有能力和时间的时候开始拾取它们。哦，有趣。是的。所以开发节奏稍微快一点。在某些周期之间停机时间要少得多，诸如此类。我认为你也不会得到那么多强有力的 KPI，比如速度和那种可预测性。但我们尝试了那个，我想，因为我们试图在某件事上移动得非常快。这并不是说你不能用 Scrum 快速移动，但这只是稍微不同
way of working at things. It's pretty cool to see that they were even open to trying out new ways of working and things like that. For the default, though, most of our teams, like I said, end up working in very Scrum-centric ways. We think about the day-to-day of our engineers. A lot of them are participating actively in those Ag agile rituals and ceremonies that come around these methodologies. For Scrum, a lot of that is sprint planning.
的工作方式。看到他们甚至愿意尝试新的工作方式等等，这很酷。不过，对于默认情况，正如我所说，我们的大多数团队最终以非常以 Scrum 为中心的方式工作。我们考虑我们工程师的日常。他们中的许多人正在积极参与围绕这些方法论的敏捷仪式和典礼。对于 Scrum，其中很多是冲刺规划。
You can think about sprint planning as, well, you have a two-week period and you want to get done X at the end of that two weeks. That's your goal for the sprint. Sprint planning is what work we're actually going to bring into those two weeks. How many issues? What are those issues going to be. It's based on obviously prioritization and the needs of the business, but that's actually a physical meeting where we sit down and we plan out what work we're going to be doing over the next two weeks before we actually start executing on it. Another really popular thing in sprints
你可以把冲刺规划想成，嗯，你有两周的时间，你想在那两周结束时完成 X。那是你冲刺的目标。冲刺规划是我们实际上要带入那两周的工作。多少个议题？那些议题将是什么。它显然基于优先级和业务需求，但这实际上是一个物理会议，我们坐下来规划我们在接下来的两周内将要做的工作，然后再开始执行它。冲刺中另一个非常流行的事情
is the idea of a retrospective. So coming together at the end of that, spending some time as a team and saying, what went really well? What do we want to improve? You know, what do we want to start doing? What do we want to stop doing? You kind of ask those meta questions of the team. And those hopefully really lead to opportunities for process change and process improvement. So our engineers are spending time in those two types of meetings. Like a lot of our engineers are also spending time on the creation and kind of scoping of new features. So one of the things, and this isn't necessarily connected to Agile,
是回顾（Retrospective）的概念。所以在最后聚在一起，花一些时间作为一个团队说，什么进展得非常好？我们想改进什么？你知道，我们想开始做什么？我们想停止做什么？你问团队那些元问题。希望这些真的能带来流程变革和流程改进的机会。所以我们的工程师把时间花在这些类型的会议上。就像我们的许多工程师也把时间花在创建和规划新功能上。所以其中一件事，这不一定与敏捷有关，
but one of the ways of working that we found really effective is what we call a three-in-the-box model. And I say we because, you know, I shouldn't say we, we actually stole it from a customer, but it was really effective. So we use it. But a three-in-the-box model essentially is product, one representative from product,
但我们发现非常有效的一种工作方式是我们称之为“三合一（three-in-the-box）”模型。我说我们是因为，你知道，我不应该说我们，我们实际上是从客户那里偷来的，但它非常有效。所以我们使用它。但“三合一”模型本质上是产品，一名来自产品的代表，
one representative from engineering, one representative from design, and all three of those stakeholders come together at the beginning of a new feature or a new product in order to participate in some high-level estimation and scoping around things. And what that helps us do is avoid those situations where design has gone through something with product. You know, you spit out this, this project to your development team and they say, yeah, it's not going to happen. And you're like, what do you mean? We spent months doing this design and all of this work that went into this. And they're like, well, I can tell you right now that it's not feasible, right? Like technically there's this blocker or this is going to be a
一名来自工程的代表，一名来自设计的代表，所有这三个利益相关者在开始一个新功能或新产品时聚在一起，以便参与一些关于事情的高级估算和规划。这有助于我们避免那种设计已经和产品一起经历了一些事情的情况。你知道，你把这个项目吐给你的开发团队，他们说，是的，这不可能发生。然后你说，你是什么意思？我们花了几个月的时间做这个设计和所有投入到这个项目中的工作。他们说，好吧，我现在就可以告诉你，这是不可行的，对吧？在技术上，有这个阻碍，或者这将是一个
huge hurdle that no one's thought of. And so we try to bring all those stakeholders together early and often in the product design process, the feature design process, so that we can get that input. And that's really just like a, you know, finger in the wind estimate at that point. We're not actually committing anyone to that, but it just helps us know when things aren't going to be possible or when we need to readjust our thinking about things. So our engineers are, you know, actively participating in a lot of those meetings as well. Um, and then, yeah, the rest of the time I think is, you know, spent, uh, spent, you know, actively doing work, actively coding, actively pair programming and working with each other on
没有人想到的巨大障碍。所以我们尽量在产品设计过程、功能设计过程中尽早且经常地让所有这些利益相关者聚在一起，以便我们能得到那种输入。那在这一点上真的只是像一个，你知道，凭经验的估算。我们实际上并没有让任何人承诺那个，但这只是帮助我们知道什么时候事情是不可能的，或者什么时候我们需要重新调整我们对事情的思考。所以我们的工程师，你知道，也在积极参与许多那些会议。嗯，然后，是的，我想剩下的时间是，你知道，花在，你知道，积极做工作，积极编码，积极结对编程并与彼此合作
things. So that makes sense. So when you're in that, in that sprint, uh, planning phase, um, does this sort of, is there sort of one person in the room who has Zen Hub open and they're basically taking notes in a sense, but they're setting that up? Or is it a thing where everyone has their laptops out with Zen Hub and they're all adding to some skeleton of the next sprint? How does that integrate with the product? It's a timely question because we're actually building a new feature in Zenhub to make that process a lot easier and make it a lot more efficient for teams.
事情。所以这很有道理。所以当你处于那个，那个冲刺，嗯，规划阶段时，嗯，房间里是否有一种人打开了 ZenHub，他们基本上是在做笔记，但他们正在设置那个？还是每个人都带着笔记本电脑，打开 ZenHub，他们都在为下一个冲刺的骨架添加内容？它如何与产品集成？这是一个及时的提问，因为我们实际上正在 Zenhub 中构建一个新功能，使那个过程更容易，并使团队的效率更高。
So I'm glad you asked that. But today, really what happens is we typically are sitting around a table. Someone will put our Zenhub board up on a screen that's in the room, like a large TV screen or something like that. We'll open up our board. We'll go to our backlog pipeline. Hopefully, that has been groomed so that it reflects kind of the most up-to-date priorities of what the business is, meaning that the highest priority items are to the top of that. And then for teams that are working in a very sprint-centric or scrum-centric way, they typically know what their relative velocity is.
所以我很高兴你问了这个问题。但今天，真正发生的是我们通常坐在桌子旁。有人会把我们的 Zenhub 看板放在房间里的屏幕上，比如大电视屏幕之类的。我们会打开我们的看板。我们会去我们的积压工作流水线。希望它已经被整理过，以便它反映出业务最更新的优先级，这意味着最高优先级的项目在顶部。然后对于以非常冲刺中心或 Scrum 中心方式工作的团队，他们通常知道他们的相对速度是多少。
And when I say velocity, it's how many issues can they take on in that two-week time span. And we go through that backlog and we say, this is what we're going to commit to essentially and try to align that with the goals of what our sprint is. Now, one of the interesting things is that we actually maintain a global backlog of work. And so teams are kind of pulling out the pieces that are a little bit more relevant to them. So we go from that global backlog into maybe specific team or team specific sprints. But yeah, there's a lot of collaboration where usually it's someone from our product team that's kind of driving that conversation. But certainly the engineers are getting a lot of feedback in terms of like, well, I think this would be a really important issue to tackle in this sprint. And this issue is actually dependency for this other issue here. So
当我提到速度时，它是指他们在两周的时间跨度内能承担多少议题。我们浏览那个积压工作并说，这就是我们基本上要承诺的，并试图将其与我们冲刺的目标对齐。现在，有趣的事情之一是，我们实际上维护了一个全球工作积压。所以团队正在提取对他们稍微更相关的一些部分。所以我们从那个全球积压工作进入也许特定的团队或团队特定的冲刺。但是的，有很多协作，通常是来自我们产品团队的人在推动那个对话。但工程师们肯定在反馈方面得到了很多，比如，嗯，我认为这将是一个在这次冲刺中解决的非常重要的议题。而且这个议题实际上是这里另一个议题的依赖项。所以
we have to do this one first. So we may as well prioritize it in this sprint so that we can work on the subsequent issues in the next sprint. Sometimes people are coming to the table and saying, hey, it's really important for this particular sprint that we include some type of work items or some type of issues that actually address technical debt. We don't want to get too far behind where we're just accruing and accruing and accruing technical debt that we have to pay off later, so let's involve some of this work in it. Sometimes it's developers that work with our customers too that are advocating for bug fixes and customer facing issues as well.
我们必须先做这个。所以我们不妨在这次冲刺中优先处理它，以便我们可以在下一次冲刺中处理后续的议题。有时人们来到桌前说，嘿，对于这个特定的冲刺，我们包含一些解决技术债务的工作项或议题非常重要。我们不想落后太多，以至于我们只是在积累、积累、积累我们以后必须偿还的技术债务，所以让我们在其中包含一些这样的工作。有时是与我们客户合作的开发人员也在倡导错误修复和面向客户的议题。
So people will be in that room and they'll say, hey, I was just on a call with X customer and this was pretty painful for them or we discovered this bug. We need to prioritize this within the sprint and be able to deliver this back to the customer kind of thing. So they advocate on the customer's behalf as well. Cool. That totally makes sense.
所以人们会在那个房间里，他们会说，嘿，我刚才和 X 客户通了电话，这对他们来说非常痛苦，或者我们发现了这个错误。我们需要在冲刺中优先处理这个，并能够将其交付回给客户。所以他们也代表客户进行倡导。酷。这完全有道理。
Yeah, I think this is something everyone should try. Every team should try, especially if you're just using Google Docs. This sounds way better. At the end of the day, yeah, I think one of the most important parts of Agile ways of working is visibility and transparency and for people on the team to be able to see what's actively being worked on. And there's obviously a lot of parts that come beyond that in terms of reporting board and understand what the priorities are that we're going to be working on and to be organizing work in that way through the lens of what's the highest priority of the business. Again, I've done a lot of talking today from a commercial sense, but
是的，我认为这是每个人都应该尝试的事情。每个团队都应该尝试，特别是如果你只是在使用 Google Docs。这听起来好多了。归根结底，是的，我认为敏捷工作方式中最重要的部分之一是可见性和透明度，以及团队成员能够看到正在积极进行的工作。除了那个之外，显然还有很多部分，在报告看板方面，了解我们将要处理的优先级，并通过业务最高优先级的视角以那种方式组织工作。同样，我今天从商业意义上讲了很多，但
you're working on an open source project. What should be feedback from your contributors as a maintainer you need to prioritize in that project in order to get more people using it or in order to better the experience for everyone that could be using that. It's a really useful exercise to actually go through. Yeah, actually, quick interjection there. So if you're working on an open source project, you typically would want to expose your project plan. So this is actually something I maintain a project called Eternal Terminal. And someone actually created an issue. It's been a while, maybe about a year ago. They created an issue basically saying, what are you doing next? Can you tell me what to expect
你正在参与一个开源项目。作为维护者，你需要优先考虑贡献者反馈的哪些方面，才能吸引更多人使用，或者为所有潜在用户改善体验？这实际上是一个非常有用的练习。是的，顺便插一句。如果你正在参与一个开源项目，通常你会希望公开你的项目计划。我维护着一个叫 Eternal Terminal 的项目，大约一年前，有人创建了一个议题，基本上是在问：你下一步打算做什么？你能告诉我该期待什么吗？
in version N plus one? And so if someone's using Zen Hub, is there a way they can sort of export something to a markdown file that just sits in the repo. So other folks who don't have Zen Hub installed can still see the roadmap. Yeah, that's a big thing that we're working on right now, bringing that visibility to teams and the individuals that may not have a need to directly authorize Zen Hub or integrate with Zen Hub. Today, the best course of action, I think,
在 N+1 版本中会有什么？如果有人在使用 ZenHub，有没有办法将某些内容导出为 Markdown 文件并放在仓库中？这样即使没有安装 ZenHub 的人也能看到路线图。是的，这是我们目前正在努力的一件大事，即为那些可能不需要直接授权或集成 ZenHub 的团队和个人提供这种可见性。我认为，目前最好的做法是，
would be for that user to actually go to our web app because you don't actually have to download something into your browser and physically have a plug-in in order to see that. You can just do it in a really nice web app wrapper. But that would be the best way I would think to do that in the product in the way that it's least most supported today. But just touching on this topic because I think it's a really interesting one. This has been something I've been writing a lot about and I think there's been a lot
让用户直接访问我们的 Web 应用，因为你实际上不需要下载任何东西到浏览器，也不需要物理安装插件就能看到这些内容。你只需在一个非常好的 Web 应用包装器中操作即可。我认为这是目前产品中实现这一目标最受支持的方式。但谈到这个话题，因为我觉得它非常有趣。这一直是我写了很多东西的主题，而且我认为已经有很多
of reading that I've done on this topic as well where you know people look at really those core tenets of agile and say like well this doesn't really jive with how open source projects work and there's this like interesting at odds of agile and open source in some ways where I actually think a lot of open source projects would really benefit from more agile ways of working primarily from a visibility and transparency standpoint of what's going to be worked on. What I mean by that is, if you go look back on the Agile manifesto, it has this emphasis on individuals and interactions over process and tools, and working software over comprehensive
关于这个话题的阅读，你知道人们审视敏捷的核心原则时会说，这与开源项目的运作方式不太契合。在某些方面，敏捷和开源之间存在一种有趣的矛盾，但我实际上认为许多开源项目如果能采用更敏捷的工作方式，会大有裨益，主要是从工作内容的可见性和透明度角度来看。我的意思是，如果你回顾敏捷宣言，它强调的是“个体和互动高于流程和工具”，“可工作的软件高于详尽的
documentation. That's fine, right? I mean, like, you know, whether or not you want to be distributed or whether or not you want to be co-located is, you know, maybe a core consideration when it comes to agile. But how many open source projects have you seen that are, you know, where people are collaborating face to face? Like they're almost all distributed. It's not going to happen. That's actually one of the benefits of it.
文档”。这没问题，对吧？我的意思是，无论你是想分布式办公还是集中办公，这可能是敏捷的一个核心考量。但你见过多少开源项目是人们面对面协作的？它们几乎都是分布式的。这行不通。这实际上是它的好处之一。
You can work from anywhere in the world with anyone in the world and to produce something really cool and amazing. And then this concept of like working software over comprehensive documentation, like if you're not going to document what you're doing in an open source project, I think anyone's going to contribute to it. Like it's just going to be a mess of trying to find out where to add value and what to work on next. And I think people see those things and are like, well, because those concepts are at odds, you know, open source projects can't be agile. And I think that's just like a really shallow way to look at things, because I think open source can really benefit from adopting agile ways of working, you know,
你可以在世界任何地方与世界上的任何人一起工作，并创造出非常酷和令人惊叹的东西。关于“可工作的软件高于详尽的文档”这个概念，如果你不在开源项目中记录你正在做的事情，我认为没人会参与贡献。这只会变成一团糟，让人难以找到增加价值的地方以及下一步该做什么。我认为人们看到这些东西时会觉得，因为这些概念是矛盾的，所以开源项目不能敏捷。我认为这是一种非常肤浅的看法，因为我认为开源项目确实可以从采用敏捷工作方式中受益，你知道，
helping to establish a process and common way of working so that everyone that wants to make a contribution to that project understands how to do that in the best way possible. Helping contributors know which issues are priority, for example. You know, how many times... That's hugely important. Right? I mean, you're gracious of any input that you get in an open source project. You're never going to be like, well, thanks.
帮助建立流程和通用的工作方式，以便每个想为该项目做出贡献的人都能以尽可能最好的方式进行。例如，帮助贡献者了解哪些议题是优先事项。你知道，多少次……这非常重要。对吧？我的意思是，你对开源项目中得到的任何输入都心存感激。你永远不会说，嗯，谢谢。
I mean, that wasn't a priority issue, but I guess it's okay that you contributed. Like, you're always appreciative people are contributing and stuff like that. But what if people knew the top issues to work on are the highest value things that they could actually work on? People crave that, too. They're coming to a project and they're being like, I really want to add value here. I want to work on something important that actually pushes this open source project along. And being able to organize work in a task board, I think, and surface what those priorities are can be really important to people.
我的意思是，那不是优先议题，但我想你贡献了也没关系。你总是很感激人们的贡献等等。但如果人们知道要处理的首要议题是他们实际上能做的最有价值的事情呢？人们也渴望这一点。他们来到一个项目时会想，我真的想在这里增加价值。我想做一些真正推动这个开源项目发展的重要事情。我认为，能够在一个任务板上组织工作并呈现出这些优先事项对人们来说非常重要。
And the last thing, which directly maps back to what you mentioned, is providing visibility and surfacing updates to the community. Showing people what those next things are that we're going to be working on as a project. maps back to what you mentioned, is providing visibility and surfacing updates to the community. Showing people what those next things are that we're going to be working on as a project. Organizing work into epics, for example, that can be tracked so that you can visualize that in Zenhub at least on a roadmap view. That's been a really interesting use case for this new feature that we launched, the roadmap view, where we had a lot of open source maintainers come back to us and say, Hey, this is amazing for being able to show where we're going next in our project, because how else do you do that? Like in a wiki and a readme, like people are trying to
最后一点，直接对应你提到的，就是提供可见性并向社区发布更新。向人们展示我们作为一个项目接下来要做的那些事情。这对应你提到的，就是提供可见性并向社区发布更新。向人们展示我们作为一个项目接下来要做的那些事情。例如，将工作组织成可以跟踪的史诗（Epics），这样你至少可以在 ZenHub 的路线图视图中将其可视化。这是我们推出的这个新功能——路线图视图的一个非常有趣的用例，我们有很多开源维护者回来告诉我们，嘿，这对于展示我们项目接下来的方向非常棒，因为除此之外你还能怎么做呢？像在维基或自述文件中吗？人们试图
parse through a bunch of different texts and like read about the history of the project, but then where you're going next, there's no really solved way to do that. And so people using roadmaps for that and Zed have has been a really cool, really cool way to do that. And so people using roadmaps for that and Zen Hub has been a really cool way to give the community visibility of what's being worked on next. Yeah, that makes sense. Also, I imagine there's some integration with GitHub proper,
解析一堆不同的文本，阅读关于项目历史的内容，但对于接下来的方向，并没有真正解决的方法。所以人们使用路线图来做这件事，ZenHub 已经成为一种非常酷的方式，让社区了解接下来要处理的工作。是的，这很有道理。另外，我想这与 GitHub 本身也有一些集成，
like in a sense, like GitHub has the tags. And so Zen Hub, I'm assuming, can sort of push high priority tags, push low priority tags. And so even if someone doesn't have Zen Hub installed, they're still going to get some rough information. Yeah, and that's kind of the beauty of the model too with integrating into GitHub.
比如 GitHub 有标签。所以我假设 ZenHub 可以推送高优先级标签、低优先级标签。这样即使有人没有安装 ZenHub，他们仍然可以获得一些粗略的信息。是的，这也是与 GitHub 集成模式的魅力所在。
It's like you pick up all the, essentially like the freebies of their product. And like milestones, for example, we repurpose for sprints. So if you know about GitHub milestones, you use them, we actually use that as the construct by which we help teams for sprints. So if you know about GitHub milestones, we use them. We actually use that as the construct by which we help teams build sprints. So even if you're not looking at a, you know, a Zen Hub board, you can still see the work that you've included in a milestone. We really heavily use, well, assignees, obviously, but labels as well. So if you're creating labels
就像你基本上获得了他们产品的所有“免费赠品”。例如，我们将里程碑（Milestones）重新用于冲刺（Sprints）。所以如果你了解 GitHub 里程碑，你就会使用它们，我们实际上将其用作帮助团队进行冲刺的结构。所以即使你没有看 ZenHub 看板，你仍然可以看到你包含在里程碑中的工作。我们非常大量地使用，嗯，指派人（Assignees）显然是，但标签也是。所以如果你在创建标签
inside of GitHub for like high priority, urgent, bug, won't fix, good first issue, stuff like that. Those are all labels that you can see on the Zen Hub cards on your board. But also, you know, if you're not using the Zen Hub board, you're not even using the product, you're still attaching labels to them. You can come and you can look at the issue list inside of GitHub, get a general sense for kind of where the priority issues are and what's being worked on by the team. So yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, there's there's a number of issues that I have in my open source project, right? Basically, I told the person, you know, submit the PR will help you, but, but, you know, we just we can't prioritize building this ourselves, right? And so, and so
在 GitHub 内部，比如高优先级、紧急、错误、不修复、好的首个议题等等。这些都是你可以在看板上的 ZenHub 卡片上看到的标签。但同样，如果你没有使用 ZenHub 看板，甚至没有使用该产品，你仍然可以给它们贴上标签。你可以查看 GitHub 内部的议题列表，对优先议题和团队正在处理的工作有一个大致的了解。所以是的，这完全说得通。是的，我的开源项目里有很多议题，对吧？基本上，我告诉那个人，提交 PR，我们会帮助你，但是，你知道，我们只是无法优先考虑自己构建这个，对吧？所以，所以
that's, that's perfect example, we're having, you know, sort of marking that as, you know, looking for help, basically. That's an invitation to anyone who wants to get started in open source. Yeah, for sure. Cool. So is Zenhub hiring and do you do internships or just full time? Always looking for great engineers and great folks to join our team, even if you're not in engineering. Like I said, our engineering and product organizations are primarily based in Vancouver. So I think for most intranet chips, we tend to want to have people physically in the office because I think in a short amount of time, that's where you can benefit the most from being close to the team. We do those as well, though. And so if you're a co-op student and you're looking for your next co-op placement, the team and to kind of contribute in moving the mission along. And so a couple of different ways, if anyone listening is kind of interested, you can check out our careers page on our website. If you see an open role that you like, by all means, apply for it.
这是一个完美的例子，我们将其标记为“寻找帮助”。这对任何想开始参与开源的人来说都是一个邀请。是的，当然。酷。那么 ZenHub 在招聘吗？你们提供实习还是只招全职？我们一直在寻找优秀的工程师和优秀的人才加入我们的团队，即使你不是工程背景。就像我说的，我们的工程和产品组织主要位于温哥华。所以我认为对于大多数实习，我们倾向于希望人们亲自在办公室工作，因为我认为在短时间内，那是你从与团队近距离接触中获益最多的地方。不过我们也做这些。所以如果你是一名合作教育学生，正在寻找下一个实习岗位，团队以及为推动使命做出贡献。所以，如果有人在听，感兴趣的话，可以通过几种不同的方式，你可以查看我们网站上的职业页面。如果你看到你喜欢的空缺职位，务必申请。
Feel free to mention my name or mention the podcast. Or if there is no open role, feel free to send me an email as well. If you mention the podcast, you get a 20% discount on your salary. 20% increase or I get a 20% discount. That's funny. Yeah. But if there isn't any open roles too, you can feel free to send me an email. It's my first name, Aaron at Zenhub.com. So yeah. Cool. So Aaron at Zenhub.com is your your email if folks want to apply for jobs, internships, ask you
随时可以提到我的名字或提到这个播客。或者如果没有空缺职位，也随时可以给我发电子邮件。如果你提到播客，你的薪水可以打八折。20% 的涨幅还是我获得 20% 的折扣？真有趣。是的。但如果没有空缺职位，你也可以随时给我发电子邮件。我的名字是 Aaron，邮箱是 Aaron@Zenhub.com。所以是的。酷。所以 Aaron@Zenhub.com 是你的邮箱，如果人们想申请工作、实习、问你
sort of like one-on-one questions. And then do you have any social media? Are you on like Twitter or any of those platforms? Yeah. So best way to get in touch with me I think is through Twitter. And on Twitter, I'm at I'm Aaron Upright. First name, last name, I'm Aaron Upright. We can probably put a link to that
一对一的问题。那么你有社交媒体吗？你在 Twitter 或其他平台上吗？是的。所以我认为与我联系的最佳方式是通过 Twitter。在 Twitter 上，我是 @AaronUpright。名字加姓氏，我是 Aaron Upright。我们可能可以放一个链接，
or actually add that to the show as well if people want to connect there. But yeah, we'd love to kind of chat with anyone there. We're pretty active in a lot of the discussions and Twitter feuds sometimes around agile because it tends to be a pretty polarizing concept. And so I'm always looking to get involved and get in touch with people there too. Cool. Awesome. Yeah. I can imagine it's from the little bit that I've like kind of read and pieced together. I've also been on Agile team. It sounds like one of these tabs versus spaces kind of things where, yeah, it starts these huge wars. But I think the important thing is not whether you use tabs or spaces, but that you sort of write a bunch of code, right? And in this case, the important thing is that you adopt, you know, one of these policies and you can sort of regulate and scope.
或者实际上也可以将其添加到节目中，如果人们想在那里联系的话。但是的，我们很乐意与那里的任何人聊天。我们经常参与很多讨论，有时还会参与关于敏捷的 Twitter 争论，因为它往往是一个非常两极分化的概念。所以我总是希望能参与其中并与那里的人联系。酷。太棒了。是的。我可以想象，从我读到和拼凑出来的一点点信息来看，我也曾在敏捷团队工作过。这听起来像是那种“制表符还是空格”之类的事情，是的，它引发了巨大的战争。但我认为重要的事情不是你使用制表符还是空格，而是你写了一堆代码，对吧？在这种情况下，重要的是你采用这些政策之一，并且你可以进行规范和界定。
And you end up not with way too many people with nothing to do and also not with completely swamped. You can kind of plan ahead of it. Yeah. And hopefully at the end of the day too, like I said, you know, better working software for your customers or, you know, contributors on your projects or people who are taking advantage of it. And that's, I think, always a great goal to have in mind. And maybe a final kind of statement to leave on is the more that you can think through that lens about, you know, how is what we're doing and how we're organizing and how we're working adding value versus just another way to work. That's going to go away and be
你最终不会出现太多人无事可做，也不会完全被淹没。你可以提前计划。是的。希望最终，就像我说的，为你的客户，或者你项目上的贡献者，或者正在利用它的人提供更好的工作软件。我认为这始终是一个值得铭记的伟大目标。也许最后可以留下一句话：你越能通过那个视角思考，即我们正在做的事情、我们如何组织以及我们如何工作是在增加价值，而不是仅仅是另一种工作方式。那将会消失并被
replaced with something in two to three years. That's always a really helpful mindset to think through. Yeah. Yeah, totally. Cool. Thank you so much. I think this is what you were able to really do is take something that seemed almost like a, like a philosophy, like this very abstract thing, and break it down into components. And I think this will definitely motivate a lot of people. And if you want to try out Agile methods, you can just integrate with ZenHub. If you're using GitHub, you can integrate with ZenHub and try it out totally for free.
在两到三年内被别的东西取代。这始终是一个非常有帮助的思维方式。是的。是的，完全正确。酷。非常感谢。我认为你真正能做到的是把一些看起来几乎像哲学、非常抽象的东西，分解成各个组成部分。我认为这肯定会激励很多人。如果你想尝试敏捷方法，你可以直接与 ZenHub 集成。如果你正在使用 GitHub，你可以与 ZenHub 集成并完全免费试用。
Is there a free trial for subscriptions or no? Yeah, there is. So for any project, even on a commercial sense, we give teams either a 14-day or a 30-day trial, depending on if you're using a growth plan or an enterprise plan. So definitely a period of try before you buy it. Cool. Yeah. So definitely try this out and get off just writing Google Docs. Trust me. I think I'm going to try it out myself. I think it sounds awesome. Awesome.
订阅有免费试用吗？是的，有。所以对于任何项目，即使是商业项目，我们也会给团队提供 14 天或 30 天的试用期，具体取决于你使用的是成长计划还是企业计划。所以绝对是一个“先试后买”的时期。酷。是的，所以一定要尝试一下，别再只写 Google 文档了。相信我。我想我自己也要试一试。听起来太棒了。太棒了。
Guys, well, thanks so much for having me. I really appreciate it. This is fantastic. Cool. Thanks, Aaron. Have a good one. Okay. The intro music is Axo by Binar Pilot.
伙计们，非常感谢邀请我。我真的很感激。这太棒了。酷。谢谢，Aaron。祝你过得愉快。好的。片头音乐是 Binar Pilot 的 Axo。
Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Programming Throwdown 是在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可下发布的。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，进行重混、改编，但你必须注明 Patrick 和我的署名，并以相同方式共享。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。